salut à tous salut tout yes alors
aujourd'hui on est pour le match
Sarine contre Guiri qui va commencer
normalement dans quelques instants alors
on a guéri qui Sarine pendant qu'il y a
quelques problèmes de tordinateur
je l'ai vu sur le zoom tout à l'heure il
avait l'air de enfin savoir bien marcher
et tout d'un coup ça a marché plus et là
je vois que sur le sur le slack c'est
une sorte de discorde professionnel et
ben ils disent qu'il a un problème
d'ordi et qui va se connecter très très
vite donc en attendant bah non
je pense c'est la bonne stratégie il va
le faire t-il
vous avez pas encore la cam de Jerry
nous on a vu et du coup
ça le fait moyennement rigoler au début
il arrive à supporter la chose là il a
trouvé un petit pion anti-stress
sponsorisé par chatcom voilà je me le
faisais remarquer
il a un match et ce beau pion je pense
que vous le verrez tout à l'heure en
direct parce que là il l'a dans la main
et on le voit bien dans les deux caméras
salut alors pour que tu saches Kevin
will creuses Nathan
il est déjà passé il nous fait des
petits coucou réguliers
dans le chat donc salut à tous ceux qui
arrivent et c'est vrai qu'on va voir un
match quand même hyper intéressant entre
Guéry qui est favoris en terme de Hello
mais Sarine c'est le spécialiste de ce
genre de cadence un peu un peu mortel
sauf particulièrement de Bullet là
encore un Regis c'est un des partenaires
de club bah ça rine aussi j'en ai parlé
un petit peu j'avais parlé de son niveau
de footballistique qui laissait à te
désirer mais par contre ambulette même
le soir après les matchs les mecs ils
cartonnaient et j'avais vu d'ailleurs ça
j'ai pas raconté Fira koto maro allez
essayer de se coller à
donc fille on peut dire que ça va être
un futur grand maître français il est
d'origine malgache et il s'est fait mais
déboîter il a pris quatre ou cinq
d'affilés et il était dégoûté et bien
sûr nous on était hyper content à côté
avec Jean-Noël d'aller regarder fils se
faire déboîter et on a dit et il dit bah
donc fille ou d'un mois il nous dit bah
allez jouer dit ah non non surtout pas
surtout pas tu vois on n'a pas été
téméraire nous on est resté boire un
petit coup tranquille avec Jean-Noël on
le regardant se faire des boîtes et moi
c'est surtout pas collé à ce genre de
match on disait qu'on gardait de
l'influx pour les matchs en partie lente
voilà comment on a fait tout pour s'en
sortir de ce guêpier voilà
nous on avait la même en Top 12 avec
avec les cookies il y avait aussi abin
tabathalay je suis toujours que ça va
t'abeille il habitait toute la semaine
avec toute l'équipe de Top 12 et je
crois qu'il a pas perdu une seule partie
et bon ok on n'est pas des énigmes mais
on a tous de 2004 et
vraiment vraiment hyper fort et par
contre bon les deux petits indiens ils
étaient plus sérieux ils jouaient pas
trop sauf un soir on a fait des
masservaux et je sens qu'avec Romu on a
mis 2-0 Google
en même temps ça c'est bon ça
c'est cool c'est franchement ils sont
ils sont chauds ils sont ils sont
talentueux et c'est le futur un peu de
chagrin indien en tout cas et donc on a
dans les équipes c'est agréable de les
avoir c'est ces jeunes Indiens parce que
on peut jouer avec eux très facilement
et sont hyper ouverts que ce soit aux
échecs au foot discuter bon tu sais bien
que mon niveau d'anglais laisse à
désirer mais globalement franchement
c'est ils sont très abordables on sait
que dans les équipes comme ça des fois
on peut se retrouver avec des grands
maîtres un peu plus austères un peu plus
focus et chaque mais sans trop échanger
et là du coup c'est vraiment agréable
qu'il y a une bonne dynamique de groupe
de bien choisir ses piliers d'équipe
pour que on passe un bon moment aussi en
plus de la compétition où on est dans
des gîtes où on est vraiment en pleine
vie de groupe dans des compétitions qui
sont difficiles c'est vrai que c'est
bien de joindre l'utile à l'agréable
quoi c'est ça alors tiens j'ai des
caméras qui viennent d'arriver donc je
vais commencer à les aller s'installer
mais je t'en prie
un petit problème les gars avec les avec
les caméras de
la caméra de de farine
et du coup
du coup je vais me mettre les caméras en
direct là vous voyez pas parce que je me
suis je me cache un petit peu mais je
vais mettre les caméras en tout cas à
l'instant
donc on pleurait en pleurer avec
Stéphane que le match
comment dirais-je ne commence pas à
l'heure parce qu'on a on a des petits
contraintes perso c'est c'est une
journée de folie pour pour Stéphane pour
moi-même il y a il y a aussi des choses
et du coup on a bien envie que ça
commence aussi pour pour qu'ils en
découlent c'est ces deux joueurs et je
crois qu'on voit que que guéri est
vraiment dans les starting blocks on
sent que il a le visage assez fermé et
ça y est Stéphane peut enfin mettre ses
caméras je peux vous dire que ça à
chaque fois un pur moment de bonheur
pour lui et il piafait d'impatience pour
mettre en avant toute sa technique et
regarder avec les anges c'est qu'elle
rapidité il nous fait ça c'est beau là
vous voyez pas encore mais ça va arriver
à mettre en même temps donc vous
inquiétez pas je vais commencer par
celle-là
il nous a mis une petite déco vous voyez
bien à lui ça va être ça va être super
sympa
un petit rideau
et une petite commode il est beau rideau
voilà et en tout cas je peux vous dire
que les pions ils risquent de bouger
vite chez NiAl alors qu'est-ce qui va
jouer Niall spécialiste du début de
Londres et ce qui va le jouer là dans
ces parties je pensais partir ultra
ultra rapide potentiellement on verra et
maintenant c'est très populaire parce
que bien sûr lui il connaît tout
là-dedans même en partie lente il l'a
joué alors il y a deux types de joueurs
il y en a qui changent un petit peu
d'ouverture et d'autres qui respectent
leur répertoire
sans aller après vraiment au bout des
choses parce que forcément ils doivent
cacher un petit peu ce qu'il joue en
partie lente vous savez que les parties
de ces tournois sont dans les bases de
données et on retrouve d'ailleurs des
choses intéressantes même en blitz ce
que je joue des joueurs de très haut
niveau comme c'est le joueur tous les
joueurs à plus de 2600 en blitz parfois
vous montre des choses dans vos propres
ouvertures et je vous des idées des fois
un petit peu hasardeuses qui ne jouerait
pas en l'an mais elles sont tout à fait
exploitables à plus petit niveau dans
les parties lentes donc ça c'est
vraiment vraiment intéressant
je sais que généralement généralement
guérit c'est le genre c'est le genre de
joueur à se préparer d'ailleurs
il va pas rigoler et il y a Nathan qui
m'a mis une bonne taille parce que tu
vois j'ai ma j'ai ma petite veste avec
une petite fourrure et je vois qu'il a
bien fait remarquer et je pense qu'elle
lui donne envie tout simplement cette
petite veste fourrure
[Musique]
en fait je me suis déjà je me suis
jamais en tenue de de sportif en dessous
et voilà je voulais pas rester un petit
t-shirt je voudrais pas prendre froid
avant avant le sport de la le sport en
nocturne et
une interprétait pas mal mes propos je
parle de badminton voilà
[Musique]
des choses comme ça là
et voilà on a échangé avec Samy aussi
Sami qui fait partie de la confrérie des
badistes
et
du coup il me disait qu'il était en
pleine progression qu'il aimerait bien à
l'occasion
taper le volant avec moi donc voilà et
ouais Michel c'est la plus belle voilà
nos amis un petit emote de DSK pour les
pour les sports
on est toujours chaud vous savez qu'avec
stuff on fait des échecs tout le temps
et bravo à toi de tenir le rythme je
trouve parce que je sais que là tu
commentes à fond les speechess et demain
je peux déjà vous dire que vous allez
pouvoir nous retrouver pour la fin des
huitièmes de finale il y aura Nakamura
demain en tout cas deux matchs
15h19h et 19h allez on va dire presque
23h demain donc de 15h à 23 heures vous
pouvez suivre les dernières
les dernières matchs de de speechess les
derniers 8ème 8ème de finale et
du coup ça va être quand même très très
sympa on va bien se régaler normalement
par rapport à tout cela d'ailleurs on se
régale à chaque fois mais c'est vrai
qu'à commenter c'est beaucoup plus
agréable quand c'est serré on a eu de la
chance on a eu l'occasion avec stouffe
de commenter la victoire de Fabiano
caroana contre arionergasis et ça avait
été super serré comme le match Levana
rognan compte Dimitri André King à
chaque fois on a parié et c'est le petit
poulain de stouffe qui a toujours gagné
voilà
pour l'instant on s'en sort pas mal
alors est-ce que tu veux qu'on soit un
retour sur le sur le bracket sur le sur
le
[Musique]
pas comment on appelle ça son tableau de
match
donc j'y suis moi moi-même parce que je
voulais rappeler qu'il restait Nakamura
par Aviane demain et aussi Abdou satora
contre westlesso voilà les les matchs
qui le qu'il reste avant le match du
jour guéri ou après le match du jour
quel signal j'ai un petit problème je
vois que ça a commencé et je vois en
fait que mon lien ne marche pas j'avais
le lien le lien des parties et du coup
bah écoute mon lien ne
on va attendre un petit peu voilà non
c'est bon on va on va on va on va mettre
des parties excusez-moi j'ai j'ai
j'avais pas vu en fait on avait un lien
vous savez pour les parties en direct
ça a commencé du coup et du coup j'avais
le lien je l'avais ouvert et puis là les
parkings sur ce pas danser
qui nous a fait part de plein de petits
débuts début du pion d'âme des 4 mais
sans ces quatre donc D4 sans jouer le
gambidam et après il jouait plein de
petits débuts laver ressort début jobava
la tarte aurait la thrombowski tout va y
passer sans doute
sans ces quatre souvent
donc plein de petits systèmes sympas et
guéri je sais que c'est un joueur qui se
prépare beaucoup c'est un genre très
très sérieux et on l'avait vu d'ailleurs
très souvent comparé moi je me souviens
j'avais vu le match contre Nakamura
Nakamura il faisait que des trucs
bizarres pour éviter les préparations
c'était assez intéressant et assez
fantasque
de styles s'affrontait tout le style
pratico-pratique on joue une position à
peu près également du côté Deniel Sarine
alors qu'à niche guéri je pense qu'il se
rapproche même dans ces cadences là en 5
+ 5 d'une certaine volonté de jouer la
vérité de jouer les coups en tout cas la
recherche du meilleur coup et de faire
mal directement ouais c'est ça
farine c'est vraiment le le grand talent
jeune qui qui joue beaucoup sur Internet
et qui est très créatif et qui clique
très très vite et très très bien et
alors que guéri comme tu le dis c'est un
joueur qui est beaucoup plus sérieux qui
est plus fort aux échecs qui est numéro
7 mondial actuellement qui a déjà eu
2800 hello et donc
voilà alors du jeu il fait tous les gros
tournois vous le savez on le voit tout
le temps et oui c'est c'est extrêmement
fort très clairement mais à cette
cadence sauf que tu me disais que les
les statistiques données 55 ans ou même
peut-être petit avantage à farine parce
que la cadence est très courte et nous
on se dit 55 ans ça semble assez normal
sur un match comme ça en fait je pense
ça va dépendre aussi pas mal de de la
forme parce que Sarine il est censé être
moins fort quand même aux échecs et s'il
est pas en forme du coup ça va être dur
pour lui par contre si l'enfant ça
marche qui est qui est hyper hyper chaud
et donc voilà
j'avais vu les oui les pronostics
qui est donc qui ont été faits par des
professionnels qui disaient que Sarine
avait l'avantage sur 60% contre 40 et
moi quand j'ai vu ça j'ai dit what enfin
ok c'est quand même
je suis conscient enfin quand tu me dis
qu'il est favori
je suis assez d'accord enfin c'est quand
c'est pas clair tu vois mais pourquoi
pas mais de là à 60 40 ça me paraît
beaucoup quand même beaucoup raison
[Musique]
donc
c'est beaucoup après bon franchement tu
as vu tous les tous les les maths qu'on
a eu jusqu'à présent on disait que c'est
des matchs pas clair et les pronostics
c'était souvent du 70-30 etc et au final
ça se finissait avec un point d'écart
je pense que nous en fait on connait un
peu mieux que leur programme qui font
qui font un petit peu dire tu vois là
leur pronostic et là pour le coup
440 non je suis pas d'accord moi je
pense que ça va être un match hyper
équilibré et où en fait le joueur qui va
être le plus en forme gagnera en fait ça
sûrement ça d'ailleurs j'ai encore en
travers cette défaite d'André King face
à rognan ou sur le fil j'y ai cru tout
et j'ai et je me suis fait banane au
moment où j'ai cru qu'en drekin allait
faire maths il allait laisser échapper
le roi mais comme un enfant mais il de
la fatigue évidemment et en tout cas on
l'a vu en direct live que ça avait
complètement déconné et c'était une
horreur à voir parce qu'au moment j'y
croyais le plus tous écroulé mais
vraiment une demi-seconde et le pire
c'est évidemment pour lui et vous savez
on parie sur les matchs donc on les vit
intensément et c'est vrai que j'étais
vert et je voyais déjà le le sourire de
tout far rivet c'était assez horrible
c'est comme casino quoi tu mises tu
mises un numéro le numéro le numéro
tombe dans le enfin la boule tombe sur
le numéro et elle ressort et de ton côté
tu vois et c'était exactement ce qui
s'est passé en fait parce que
franchement tu avais la coupe dans la
main et je te je te la race de la main
je l'ai prise pour moi tu vois c'est
vraiment ça quand
alors en fait depuis le casino le début
bah je laisse quasiment tout le temps
Kevin je veux dire son poulain en fait
ok je peux pas lutter parce qu'en fait à
chaque fois
les joueurs de son équipe de Top 16 et
ben je voulais match donc il veut parler
sur eux ce qui est tout à fait normal et
on aura et du coup ben moi je prends
l'autre et pour l'instant on a tout
gagné donc je suis assez content ouais
c'est terrible c'est terrible et le seul
que j'aurais pris c'était vraiment à
rognon on va dire en terme de jeu et bam
bah je me suis retrouvé avec enreg King
qui a fait un super match en plus ce qui
est très fort le 50/50 perdu comme on
dit hein voilà le corn flip
voilà et en tout cas Niall Sarine dans
cette première partie il prend tous les
pions alors il était très très bien
autant NiAl il avait bouffé une minute
dans le début après elle a été gobée des
pions et il a vu que c'était
véritablement dangereux et maintenant il
continue à bouffer des pions mais c'est
chaud dans un deuxième parce que ben vu
qu'il est arrivé jusque là je pense
qu'il faut manger
maintenant c'est chaud parce que là
j'essaie de voir parce que l'ordinateur
il est il pense que les noirs sont
beaucoup mieux donc nous encore on n'a
pas l'ordinateur sous les yeux hein moi
je pensais à damascal G3 et d'un G5 mais
après rock je croyais pas la suite
c'était rigolo
qui va arriver
sûrement et du coup comment est-ce qu'il
va comment
éviter
je sais pas ce que ça va mais on appuie
sur B2 et peut-être je t'interdis la
case
là je vais bouger mon pion et la tour V6
tu peux plus venir là
je peux faire tourner 8 et Tours C8
aussi il y avait tout ab8 et tout FC 8
par la suite donc c'était intéressant
ce qui force la dame avait à rester
sur le fou elle est tombé vite tu
menaces pas et puis en B2 c'est une idée
donc torse 8 Dame des 6
et là il faut
terminer
parce que sur A4 j'ai dame prend B5
[Musique]
qui est droit qui avait l'air
intéressant
voilà est-ce que je peux vous enlève de
roi G3 et partir de
pouvoir en fait parce que si le roi
reste la première rangée je prends un
tort sur un chèque après je prends le
temps et sur W9 chèque voilà après j'ai
grâce à Adam j'ai plus qu'à chercher un
diagonale et ça peut être compliqué
mais il peut cliquer comme un dingue
donc bon c'est moins grave pour lui que
pour certains c'est comment tu peux
chaud parce que même pour un fou du
Bullet quand l'adversaire a un petit peu
de temps et que vous vous êtes vraiment
en Ultra zinote ben vous pouvez vous
faire avoir mais c'est quand même sa
spécialité ça chez le comment tu joues
ici tu prends et tu tournes
je pensais prise pour ces 6 faut bouge
et donc en V2 j'ai toujours un pion de
moins mais j'ai vachement activité que
la tension la seconde parce que
je trouve quelque chose
c'est pas mal quand même
en fait
voilà l'autre
pas facile il faut prouver salut
comment vas-tu
parce que maintenant ok petit attaque
avec l'idée de faire le rock vite
franchement
tu as l'impression que ça va perdre
quelque chose mais tu vas tout recettes
dame C6
il faut trouver c'est pas facile ça fait
depuis tout à l'heure qu'il Adam D8
maintenant peut-être il a réussi
à la pièce 3 pions incroyables et ok bon
il se bat maintenant
[Musique]
ça semble ça semble quand même perdu
mais il faut faire gaffe position on a
déjà perdu des comme ça souffle
le roi arrive et c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer le roi ici et mettre
la tour et ça devrait ça devrait gagner
un E5 pousse le Pione pour l'instant
petite victoire pour guérir dans cette
première partie
aussi malgré la crise de temps on voit
qu'il la gère très bien
il a mangé sur le chat il y a une petite
découverte
plus de temps à la pendule mais quand
même normalement
deux pions en tout cas il a montré
quelque chose lyrics c'était quelqu'un
de fort aussi bon c'est un mec génial en
partie lente mais même dans le Bullet il
a été présent
moi je l'avais joué en Bullet guéri et
il me l'avait bien collé bon je fais un
référence encore
après ok tu compares avec un peut-être
un autre joueur de Bullet tu vois
d'ailleurs j'ai vu que diri il avait
2003 3200 ambulettes sur Swisscom qui
quand même traduit quelque chose de
d'assez intéressant d'ailleurs bon il
est accolé elle est 1-0 pour guéri mon
petit poulain
[Musique]
avec un 3 elle est pas mal cette ligne
sauf pour envoyer tous les pions on a
des faiblesses C4 et C3 et on va envoyer
tous les pions on va faire E4 et après
faut des trois F4 elle est j'aime bien
la jouer de temps en temps salut à
Rennes
très très dynamique cette ligne avec les
Blancs le problème c'est le long terme
l'option C4 mais on peut on peut faire
des parties de folie
et là le plan c'est pas mal de pas jouer
D6 avec les Noirs parce que des fois le
cavalier F6 peut rebondir en E8 D6 les
idées comme ça ouais
c'est ça de massacrer le pion C4 pour
les noirs
et avec les Blancs c'est de massacrer le
roi noir voilà on a vu une idée comme ça
hier dans le match avec Carlsen
Carlson avec l'idée de venir aller
manger le pion en saisir
mot mais le thème c'est un peu le même
et là du coup ben là il va cavaler 8 qui
est normal et après je sais pas comment
on réagit dans cette position je suis
pas un expert mais je sais que c'est
normal pour les Noirs normalement de se
laisser pousser
les pions et mettre le cavalier en 1 et
8 donc les Blancs ont un gros espace
avant d'espace mais retardement mais le
pion en C4 qui va être dur à défendre si
jamais j'arrive
ramener une pièce à sur l'attaque tu
pions C4
parce que normalement ce genre de
position c'est
c'est assez théorique alors il a fait il
a fait vraiment eu 5 très rapidement ce
qui avait quelque chose et ce qui va les
faire des six normalement non parce que
je rappelle d'une partie où je me suis
pris ce fameux plan avec
cavalier 8 cavaliers des 6 donc ça
m'intéresse de voir
non c'est presque ça par contre il joue
pendant 1h30 le 5 + 1 il joue pendant
une heure le 3 + 1 et pendant 30 minutes
le 1 + 1 voilà et ça fait déjà des
matchs d'à peu près 3h30 qui ce qui est
déjà vraiment intense même pour ces
joueurs exceptionnels on voit qu'à la
fin des matchs en 1+1 ça fatigue des
fois des deux côtés et du coup il y a
des drames
pour casser le fou des trois sinon il y
avait des vrais menaces de fou pour un
chèque cavalier G5 j'aime beaucoup ce
que dit Templiers j'aime beaucoup ce que
dit est-ce qu'on peut le mettre VIP sur
la chaîne
n'importe quoi n'importe quoi tu vas
voir que ce soir j'inverse la tendance
puis j'avais déjà vraiment l'an dernier
c'était tout à fait l'inverse et du coup
ah oui
de couches
de lui laisser et puis je vais le
fidéliser un peu comme dans les parcs je
laisse les deux premières après je je
reviens à bloc qui reste plus beaucoup
pour venir un blog quand même
alors
pour les victoires c'est un point par
victoire un demi point par match nul et
0 point en cas des fêtes et cela pour
toutes les cadences voilà chaque partie
voit un point et en bas vous avez quand
même il y a un tableau en dessous du de
l'échiquier avec la cadence et le score
dans chaque cadence si vous voulez mais
à la fin le total et ben c'est c'est de
tous les points si je perds par exemple
je sais pas 5 4 5 4 les deux premiers 7
et qu'après je gagne 0 je gagne
parce que j'ai gagné beaucoup plus de
parties en fait c'est pas les 7 qui
comptent c'est les points les points
exactement et il y a une pause toutes
les milieux de de séquences donc là il y
a une heure trente de 5 + 1 et du coup à
45 minutes vous verrez qu'elle timer en
haut et ben au milieu du premier segment
et ben il y aura une pause de 5 minutes
et puis après ça reprendra repose avant
les trois plus un et encore pareil pose
au milieu de 3 + 1 puis à la fin et par
contre en but là tu auras pas de pause
parce que ça dure une demi-heure et puis
c'est un peu dur de pas être beau au
milieu du bulletin tellement ça va vite
parce que c'est mon partenaire de club
donc il y avait pas trop le choix on
était bloqué avec stouf chacun de notre
côté la dernière fois qu'on a fait ça
bah malheureusement mon partenaire de
club érygazy avait perdu contre le
poulain de de stouffe qui n'était autre
que Fabiano carwana voilà c'était pas
mal quand même moi j'aurais voulu parier
ce que fait Sarine mais est-ce que c'est
correct il vient de donner la qualité
pour les cases blanches
empêcher le rock et venir à s'installer
sur casse blanche sachant que le foot 15
mars sera enfermé intéressant niveau
stratégique ce qui fait
en tout cas tout le monde voit Guiri
gagnante
[Musique]
les bookmakers
rien c'est c'est gaillard salut Fatou la
petite fiscale d'ailleurs d'ailleurs je
vais rebondir ce que tu sur ce que tu as
dit parce que hier on a pas parié bien
sûr sur le match qu'on a pas enfin
un tel bonheur excuse-moi mais ça rime
ah pardon gokash cette année je joue
pour ton équipe
oui ou non
ça va j'ai pas regardé
au courant mais personne m'averti et
d'ailleurs je vais appeler mon capitaine
de c'est peut-être ça qui voulait alors
la faute de date de quand
de quoi longtemps déjà un moment je l'ai
pas vu et mon capitaine d'équipe voulait
m'appeler tu vois hier et aujourd'hui je
devais le rappeler tu vois bah comme je
fais des commentaires je peux là je peux
pas je m'en excuse auprès de lui
si tu avais pris le match hier tu
m'aurais dit que j'aurais dû bête sur
mon moulin mais c'est quand même mon
poulain qui qui est ton partenaire cette
année donc tu me mets au courant parce
que c'était pas le cas l'an passé et
du coup l'ambiance est tellement bonne
que on a l'air d'avoir un filon indien
sauf au niveau ouais c'est génial tout à
fait oui oui avec Sarine avec ça
qui est un peu moins connu mais il a
moins de moins de 20 ans et joue hyper
bien entre 25,50 et 26 donc avec
designotes incroyables d'ailleurs il se
met très mal au temps il se bat
en tout cas ni à la fin un sacrifice de
qualité positionnelle très intéressant
pour les cases blanches mais il y a une
colonne j'ai ouverte les cases noires
aussi le foie F2 est en train de se
mettre là où il faut pour sortir ça sent
pas hyper bon cette position
et commencer l'attaque
en plus au niveau du Time pour l'instant
c'est pas brillant j'ai l'impression
vite alors que c'est le joueur qui on va
dire
plutôt en mode généralement qui vient
aussi attaquer les faiblesses cavaliers
généralement il faut essayer de le
bloquer avec un cavalier si vous pouvez
est-ce qu'on peut pas faire je voulais
faire si c'est cavalier H4 pour essayer
de mixer nos idées c'est chaud parce que
le roi pouvait bouger mais très
intéressant pour moi c'était peut-être
une clé
avant en fait il y a peut-être dans mes
7 qui empêche du coup peut-être que mon
cou était bizarre mais comme
pour l'instant je trouve pas de
livraison incroyable non c'est clair
salut
actuellement bon depuis son son titre de
j'aime je l'ai vu un petit peu pierre
mais malheureusement j'ai un ami qui
organisé une fête voilà pour son titre
et ça tombait mal c'est un moment où je
n'étais pas présent mais là ça fait un
petit moment que j'ai pas eu de
nouvelles de Pierre il est possible que
je le vois en vacances de Noël
mais en tout cas pas de nouvelles
fraîche sous-ang
j'aime beaucoup les blancs j'aime
beaucoup les blancs
il faut voir comment il perce les
lanières sans doute il a l'idée voilà
si il fait rien moi je rentre avec le
cavalier à 5 et tout ça maintenant il a
tout ouvert et ça va être donc il a
rendu une pièce donc là le matériel il a
une tour pour deux pièces mais j'ai une
case dans un 5
j'ai les tours qui vont rentrer sur la
7e et bien joué pour une mais ça n'a pas
suffi et puis pour l'instant on voit que
il est jamais surpris
il anticipe tout il est très mal là
avec toi
mon petit Kevin
et oui oui oui je suis dépité de ton de
ton pronostic
là c'est pas
le petit match pour l'instant je te
rappelle je te rappelle que Fanny en 7
r classique
sa structure là on aime bien ces quatre
généralement salut thé vert il avait
l'air un peu dépité l'a mis
la mignonne il a fait un petit rictus
sans doute perturbé par ces problèmes
d'ordinateur
il y a eu un petit cadre retard à cause
du de l'ordinateur de Sarine je sais pas
ce qui se passait il avait un problème
est-ce que tu as fait la remarque de
5000 qui dit en fait j'arrive pour
réduire Kevin mis sur un joueur du coup
on sait qu'il va perdre le match et on
rentre l'entraîne ça ne passe pas comme
ça je peux je peux vous dire je peux
vous dire que il va faire le réveil NiAl
en tout cas j'ai intérêt d'y croire
c'est les marchands de paille
hello à tous
ceux qui nous rejoignent alors
du coup c'est un petit peu pénible en
tout cas guéri va prendre la confiance
et ça ça m'inquiète un petit peu
là attention qu'est-ce que je joue sur
son cou autour B8 je joue quoi danser
on va montrer ce qui se passe il y a
tout reprend B2 qui va arriver peut-être
avec tout reprend et fou prends C3
ça m'étonne qu'il est pas vu ça
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait je pense qu'il
mais en fait tu gagnes qu'un pion mais
je pense que ce qu'il veut c'est manger
le foot quasiment
peut-être et si tu manges une tour et
après tu as des problèmes je pense qu'il
est dans cette optique là de d'essayer
de vouloir jouer sur le cadre clairement
et c'est pas si mal
qui est la meilleure manière de perdre
ce pion
ton P8 voilà donc faut prendre
il y a des problèmes sur le cavaliers C5
éventuellement mais aussi sur le CASE
noires
[Musique]
et dame c'est trop tu vois
donc là il y a eu tams j'aime bien ce
coup-là
c'est malin encore parce que ça a gagné
par exemple et du coup je peux pas
manger parce que je parlais ma tour tu
vois
et c'est l'automatal
qui gère aujourd'hui
il a bien géré cela parce que
on l'a dit c'est signal qui a des petits
problèmes ouais non mais
c'est assez facile
à mettre en place
est-ce que c'est pas un petit moins
c'est possible ouh là là gros E5 direct
et jouer sur les pions faibles mais bon
f pro j'ai l'impression que
il peut manger je fous de 4 peut-être un
truc comme ça mais c'est ça qui voulait
tout rein on harcèle les pions et c'est
assez joli
alors maintenant est-ce que c'est bon ça
c'est autre chose parce que il va en
récupérer un et puis sinon on
vraisemblablement mais est-ce que il va
récupérer deux
c'est ça qui est dur
je voulais jouer aussi pour interdire
Tourcoing j'écarte peut-être
je me sens fort tu vois et du coup
qui pourrait arriver aussi et mais en
tout cas les Noirs ce qui essaient de
faire c'est échanger des pièces tu vois
ils ont deux pions de plus ils vont
sûrement en perdre un mais du coup genre
j'ai des pièces c'est que jamais
j'ai 4 et là du coup c'est dur de jouer
tourger 5 pourquoi parce que la tour est
enfermée donc on peut jouer au roi F1 F3
par exemple ça fait peur et de tenir
l'enfermement de la tour pendant
longtemps voilà donc il a pas voulu de
ça
de plus mais il y a plein de faiblesses
les deux joueurs dames ici c'est bien
stouf je pense parce que on va chercher
du contre jeu
mesdames Messieurs Je me note des échecs
et je vois un peu
F7 très stable et après ouais dame de 6
1 2 3 peut-être la séquence
c'est quoi le but du jeu
[Musique]
en fait c'est un match il y a trois
cadences de jeux il y a 5 pouces 1 3 + 1
et une plus un et en fait tous les
tous les points comptes un taille-haie
break puis à la fin on compte le score
tout ça
maintenant tu es passé j'aime dans en
pronostic dans
une Moussa alors là pour le coup
j'espère que tout le monde va bien de
poisser quoi punaise qu'est-ce que ce
serait bon une belle pointe tu sais donc
pour toi la poisse alors il y a un
maître à Noël que je je ne dirais pas
son nom
là en public mais que j'ai battu un
tournoi qui a très longtemps quand je
voulais passer je crois que j'avais fait
deux normes de mi et j'avais 2350 donc
je commençais un peu à chauffer tu vois
pour être maître et il y a un ami que
j'ai battu un peu Salma j'avoue et il
m'a dit un peu fâché il m'a dit mais son
toi tu seras jamais aimé
et je sens du coup la malédiction de ce
gars parce que du coup j'ai fait ma
troisième norme de MI en 2016 et là du
coup six ans après j'ai cinq normes
si Jean c'est long après toutes ces
normes j'avais fait trois ça m'a déjà
bien calmé mais six ans ça commence à
être long
et je lui hello qui tourne entre 2300 50
et 80 etc tu fais des petits bons
mais pour l'instant les petits bons
en arrière maintenant il faut que je
après je l'ai refait en avant mais
maintenant il me faut un petit bon en
avant quand même là
il est mal au temps guéri et puis ça
commence à être dangereux pour lui il
mène 2-0 il a c'est pas du tout
il va prendre la nul je pense tranquille
il y a pas le choix je crois vraiment on
va pas pousser F3 dans ses positions et
se faire ma tête donc du coup moi j'ai
trois ça va être encore échec alors à
l'époque il y avait une expiration je
crois 10 ans c'est normal mais
maintenant c'est terminé c'est à vie
donc du coup voilà j'espère que ce jeu
j'ai toute ma vie
on va pas aller en s'arrangeant mon
petit stouf donc ça va me convertir
est-ce que toi c'est pas mal idée de de
me lasser là et aussi là c'est rigolo
mais tu fais quoi en fait ça juste
F4
maintenant Roger
du coup
tu fasses tour 8 ce que j'ai le droit de
faire un coup comme tour des trois temps
de tour 8
en fait il faut toujours un coup juste
si j'attends
je joue
à garder
c'est pas grave mais
on peut aussi jouer peut-être dans mes
deux j'aimerais bien jouer une
perspective avec mais c'est dur à mettre
en place à cause du projet
si tu vois ce message
[Rires]
bienvenue alors c'est qui très de
malédiction pour le titre je sais pas
[Musique]
je sais pas
et après pour vous dire la vérité je
connais pas bien le prix des abonnements
c'est comme
je connais pas le tracteur
Nathan il va il va il va gérer tout ça
est-ce que tu penses que pour la faute
qui est qui a eu il va faire des promos
aujourd'hui dans le chat je pense qu'il
peut distribuer un petit tableau et je
pense que
[Rires]
[Musique]
il va bouffer à 5 je pense ils aiment
bien les joueurs indiens bouffer le
matos j'ai vu herigasis bien le faire
[Musique]
un petit peu
il a réussi à créer un déséquilibre et
surtout en fait il y a un gros problème
au temps en fait chez trop mal au temple
parce que comme on a dit
il faut mais c'est pas facile ce qu'il
faut jouer à 4 dans cette position tout
autre il va essayer de faire des petites
menaces
revenir peut-être pour refaire échec
voilà et maintenant ce qu'on envoie le
pion voilà il fallait l'envoyer de façon
à un moment
allez on envoie encore peut-être je vois
pas comment il parle
c'est important
superbe il a oublié le temps il a oublié
le temps mais c'était franchement
clairement
je suis bien content là parce que sinon
ça pouvait mal tourner mais cette
il a été très combatif NiAl il a posé
des problèmes pratiques on voit vraiment
son style la position était sans doute
égale mais il pose des problèmes posent
des problèmes posent des problèmes
non c'est pas parce qu'il a fait c'est
vrai comme le dit triste un deuxième
pion pour jouer en fait sur les
faiblesses sur le long terme et du coup
c'est hyper intéressant ce qu'il a fait
et
mais bon il était mal de toute façon
donc je pense que il a bien fait le côté
pratique c'était quand même hyper
intéressant comme décision café Sarine
et du coup stérile avec cette partie qui
revient à deux quand même donc il est il
est proche de revenir pas non plus la
panacée non mais ok si là c'était quand
même dramatique
là du coup il est revenu c'est quand
même cool en plus la partie était bonne
enfin bonne il a créé des choses quand
même il a réussi à jouer son jeu il y a
un posé un petit peu sa loin c'est parti
il a 18 ans maintenant
bien joué tes Vermande pour le code
promo à moins 20% sur les abonnements
diamants avec le code né en 10 alors je
crois que c'est sans accent
sur les codes promo c'est mieux
c'est intéressant quand même pour pour
libérer toutes ces pièces un coup à la
stouffe
c'était le coup là il y avait des seins
qui va arriver voilà moi j'aime bien les
Noirs
tu vois quand j'arrive à
des fois j'ai un coup avec F6 pour aller
éliminer le pion qui est en E5 et j'ai
souvent en fait ce type de position en
fait une fois que tu le dessin qui est
ben du coup le centre blanc est
difficile à apprendre
je pense que certains d'entre vous
donnez en dentaire ils vont être
embauchés par
Nathan puisque là il y a plein d'idées
sur les codes promo sur le marketing
chasse come fr donc là bravo à vous bien
jouer maintenant en tout cas pour la
dernière
[Musique]
il est bien plus âgé
et pas im ah oui
marchand de paille international et lui
il est il est maître international mais
français quand même moi je suis maître
breton
avec un gros sur toute l'arrière toute
la vitre arrière de la voiture
énorme drapeau breton
je suis au fond au fin fond des Canaries
ils sont encore à des Bretons quoi
casquette et donc là on revoit Nathan
qui est venu régler le problème qu'il y
avait sur
la casquette officielle on voit que
c'est pas la même est-ce que tu penses
qu'il vient donner l'abonnement à noiral
parce que
en Afrique de l'Ouest
après nous le canari c'est presque
l'Afrique on n'est pas loin du Maroc
[Applaudissements]
qui n'a pas son épée elle est désarmée
ça me fait ça me fait très bizarre de
voir ça
en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on fait le savoir
alors vous êtes trois puis on prend et
grande difficulté quand même dans cette
position avec toutes les pièces qui sont
à aller toutes les pièces sur le roi
blanc ouais c'est ça les pièces blanches
sont impression qu'elles sont parties là
je sais pas quel côté
je suis là mais et du coup je donne pas
très cher de la peau de de guéri dans
cette partie
mais bon
c'était ça la question de tout bouffer
et ça semblait là encore il aime bien
gober les pions envoyer et puis le roi
et il est à poil là le roi
blancs
les pièces noires qui arrivent très très
vite
ils sont très loin le cavalier qui peut
venir aussi ça peut arriver très vite
des pièces blanches sont hyper loin j'ai
du mal à venir
là je peux vous dire qu'il est grande
difficulté pas jouer tout de suite je
pense guérir c'est pas le coup qu'on a
envie de jouer à tempo avec les
pas mal de menaces et surtout E5 tout
est-ce que je fais tout
dans 2 peut-être aussi hein
[Musique]
punaise pourtant ça fait pas rêver mais
il a trouvé une défense incroyable et à
une vitesse surtout
très très impressionnante
et oui d'ailleurs il y a une vidéo
YouTube où les gens IRL en blitz contre
guéri c'était un tournoi que j'ai fait
un tournoi de Bullet que j'ai fait à
Tilborg Bullet de plus zéro en IRL
il y avait vachement moins il y avait
guérir et les jeux deux fois et une des
parties et sur Youtube donc tu peux la
trouver je pense tu marques bressac-giry
YouTube toi tu peux trouver un longtemps
à l'époque j'avais des lunettes je me
suis fait opérer de la myopie
des mauvais souvenirs je te remercie Pat
parce que moi j'ai joué qu'on y a le
Sarine quand il avait 11 ans à
Cappelle-la-Grande et j'avais pris une
bonne je l'ai prévenu que le petit monde
jouait très bien il était alors
vice-champion du monde des moins de 12
il venait de battre un grand maître
faire nul avec un grand maître donc je
savais que ça allait être chaud et en
fait il me l'avait collé à la régulière
c'est à dire que j'avais fait plutôt une
bonne partie par rapport à ce que je
suis censé faire ce que je peux faire
mais il avait il avait joué de manière
exceptionnelle alors qu'il avait 11 ans
il était alors 2280 au classement
d'après il était 2470 déjà donc c'était
c'était vraiment hyper hyper chaud
bien dégueu en tout cas mais bien cassé
mon tournoi le petit môme
en plus vieux quand même
2600 hello quand il avait 14 ans il
avait 2400 déjà
donc ça va
que moi donc du coup c'est normal qui me
battent en fait mais il avait été
impressionnant
impressionnant ça peut être très très
bien joué
clairement
même un stage là et du coup depuis la
consolidation fougère fois H2 qui était
très difficile à trouver ben il y a
Niall qui se casse les dents parce que
c'est pas facile d'avancer franchement
c'est joli hein oui j'aime beaucoup le
dernier coup de NiAl qui parce que un
des problèmes c'est d'enlever sa tour E8
et à chaque fois il y a des thèmes de
maths du couloir donc il joue ce petit
haschiste pour consolider son roi avec
roi Hachette c'est extrêmement malin
c'est un coup profil actif sauf qu'ils
le font avec 30 secondes à la pendule
quoi
et fuer pas loin de chez stuff très
sympa j'ai fait aussi Templiers et
c'était cool
et oui il a chaud autant NiAl
normalement il très doué dans ce genre
de config mais
la partie ah oui il y a très très
longtemps
il est un peu dingue NiAl parce que il
sait qu'il a dû rater un petit peu
quelque chose
mais il a pas de quoi être dingue il
faut qu'il embraye maintenant il doit
pas jouer avec trois secondes il faut
qu'il profite de ces 17 secondes
mais j'aimerais bien aller c'est les
plages sont complètement folles c'est
un truc de ouf
il y a pas mal de il y a pas mal de
émulation en tout cas dans ces pays que
ce soit même
Ouzbékistan le Kazakhstan l'Inde tous
les pays un peu
là ça commence à être pas mal pour les
pour les blancs j'ai l'impression j'ai
pas grand chose pour les Noirs alors il
y a quand même trois qui fait fourchette
tout le temps qui m'inquiète parce qu'il
y a quand même un différentiel très fort
il a il a bouffé un petit peu de pendule
pour pour jouer ces séquences c'est pire
en pire là est-ce que tu peux faire non
je pense faire ton jeu 3
ce qui permet de découverte voilà
pourquoi il a joué ce coup très
rapidement
ils sont malins franchement
de Bullet donc du coup
c'est important d'être très précis
est-ce qu'on peut jouer il y a beaucoup
de coups candidats
magnifique il a été obligé de contrer ça
mais avec plus de temps à la pendule
est-ce qu'il y aurait pas échanger tout
F3 ce qu'on peut faire ça tu reprends G5
tours est-ce que ça tient
c'est trouver c'est ce qui fait c'est
perdu
et il perd la partie
il a dominé et il a pris pour moi il a
perdu autant encore fait deux parties
qu'on voit qu'ils sont inversés à cause
du temps c'est ça et est-ce que c'est la
pause s'ouvre c'est la pause on avait
dit à la moitié du temps et ben c'est la
pause donc
on va faire une petite pause
ne partez pas à rester ici sur
cheeseccom FR d'ici 5 minutes on va
revenir avec Kevin pour la suite de ce
premier set en 5 + 1 il reste 43 minutes
35 secondes et beaucoup de parties a
vraiment très intéressantes et très
intense donc pour l'instant Guy men 3 1
dans ce set
et donc voilà à tout de suite et
vous savez pas quoi faire allez voir nos
sites Internet respectifs avec stouf
comme ça voilà on vous donne un petit
peu de travail pendant les pauses
allez on vous dit à tout de suite avant
de partir je vais mettre juste mettre le
lien de ta chaîne et voulu si un peu
long quand même
la mienne je peux pas vous la mettre si
un mot devant le chat et ce qui est un
mot dans le chat qui pourrait mettre le
petit sauce pouf pour pour montrer un
petit peu
non il faut être modo malheureusement et
fatoumodo sur cette chaîne là pas encore
mais on va écrire un mail
[Rires]
donc je vous dis à bientôt les gars et
enfin à toi à tout de suite 5 minutes
allez à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour dans ce match
ça commence
même pas faite
il faut qu'il se reprenne
parce qu'il est mené 3 1 alors ok c'est
le 5 + 5 donc dans les autres cadences
il peut revenir mais il faut pas qu'il
se laisse distancer de trop
après le match suivant est capable de
d'être très très bon aussi
ambulette donc on va voir un peu ce qui
se passe en tout cas toutes les cadences
sont vont être chaudes c'est vraiment un
match assez équilibré sur le papier
généralement après à chaque pause on a
vu des fois des choses un petit peu
différentes donc du coup faut espérer
que nia elle arrive à se remettre
d'autant plus que là il vient de perdre
une partie qui était vraiment en très
bonne voie avec une grosse attaque sur
le roi franchement la défense de guéri a
été extraordinaire
il a trouvé comme un coup fougé en fou
H2 à une vitesse de l'espace et a réussi
à tenir une position très compromise et
je pense que ils sont morts les doigts
NiAl et qu'il va falloir faire le deuil
de cette défaite pour continuer à bien
jouer franchement on voit quand même que
que
en forme en ce match
il joue vraiment bien il jouit et il est
efficace
c'est vrai après c'est toujours pareil
je me disais que ça après le 2-0 mais il
a pris 2-1 puis après il pouvait perdre
et ça peut vite se vriller ce genre de
match en tout cas il a réussi à
conserver son avance ça peut vraiment
vraiment tourner rapidement dans les
deux sens donc voilà après guéri ce que
c'est un joueur qui peut tilter
peut-être
il est assez stable en tout cas mais
s'il commence à se faire enquiller par
le petit jeune ça peut commencer à
devenir un petit peu difficile
mais bon pour l'instant c'est pas le cas
en terme de préparation théorique je
trouve que dans les débuts il obtient
toujours des situations assez
confortables mises à part la partie
précédente qui est peut-être la seule où
il a été mis à mal dans dans le début
mais il a des cases au centre et le plan
des cinq qui est bon qui est là mais
comment dire
connu ce petit dispositions
[Musique]
et à la fois on est plus bloqué avec nos
pièces que si on avait le pion isolé
mais c'est vrai que c'est exactement la
position de carreaux canne Panov avec le
pion en plus quoi
donc du coup ça brille le fou des deux
qui va sans doute aller en 1 peut-être
là
à moins qu'on puisse faire cavalier
prend le cadre il faut prendre le 4 ou
C3 aussi il faut que j'arrive à défendre
la vidéo ça c'est clair qu'il va prendre
une décision mais c'est pas facile parce
qu'il y a quand même le fond là
maintenant aussi
et il faut trouver la bonne la bonne
défense cavaler prend faut prendre fous
ces trois
voilà bon c'est toujours mon pion de
plus mais bon
après faut voir du coup comment tu vas
regarder depuis en plus dans quelles
conditions
parce que ça peut surtout un peu contre
toi des fois
ce que GF quand même pour avoir envie
aussi pas toujours des bonnes positions
donc à voir
là dans les deux dernières parties on a
vu l'impact de la pendule donc j'espère
vraiment
moi qui supporte NiAl qui va se
réveiller
il est concentré on le voit on le voit
la caméra il est vraiment hyper
concentré il prend ce match
cavalier G5 il a un vélo
initiative sur ce coup-là kfg5 très bien
joué
et là il va réussir en fait à comme tu
le dis prends l'initiative prendre les
commandes un peu de la partie
super
mais
c'est pas forcément non plus quelque
chose de bien
stop
il est pas rangé la chambre et puis
[Musique]
il dormait bref c'était un SketchUp
intermédiaire très intéressant
là qui sont très présents
donc ça prime quand même sur le fou et
D6 qui a été envoyé sont impronestimeux
perpétuellement de prendre l'initiative
parce que ils savent qu'après une fois
que l'adversaire est dominé n'a plus
d'idées ils seront mettre des éléments
mais c'est quoi
malheureusement c'est la galère
peut-être juger trois
quand même
pas facile de tout tenir donc il a mangé
ici
un NiAl se réveille dans ses positions
un peu complexes
indiens comme ça
c'est vraiment l'école un peu calcule
tranquillement laisser une carte
prise G6 peut-être tout simplement prise
on aura quand même peut-être un peu plus
à la fin quoi c'est ça le problème
souffre
petit avantage blanc et j'aurais plutôt
dit
une grosse avantage blanc est-ce qu'on
peut bouffer B2 et jouer tour C2 j'y
crois pas
[Musique]
en tout cas pas si facile ça te pose
il est sous pression en fait j'aime bien
c'est configsia arrive à la à embêter à
niche et lui poser des problèmes autant
ça c'est les meilleurs config ben c'est
ça parce que
c'est clairement les positions dans
lesquelles il va être plus fort que que
dirige pense hein
il joue vite de jouer ses positions fous
des 4 c'est encore un grand coup attaque
F2 je l'ai pas vu non plus
et là du coup maintenant il faut
défendre rêve de camin c'est un peu
important en plus c'est découverte à 92
comment on
défendif ou trois
F2
c'est quand même il y a la tour il y a
une découverte derrière c'est pas un
truc que tu veux te prendre
je pense qu'il y avait H3 c'est
extrêmement passif
avec l'idée de tout reprendre un
je le montre avec
il faut prendre F2 il faut prendre
la position de NiAl mais je trouve qu'il
a trouvé un bon coup ici à niche que
j'avais loupé et maintenant toujours
cette tendance à l'initiative dans les
deux camps c'est hyper intéressant vous
voyez il se rendent coup pour coup et
c'est important pour pas laisser la
prise davantage arriver
je pensais
là
fourchette ça attaque cavalier et ça
partout quoi et après
une bonne réflexion
c'est peut-être le meilleur coup hein
bon j'ai vu cavaluer
qui est intéressant
je comprends mieux le coup
alors pris G6 oubliée je pense
oh
je pense que
il a oublié
avec 50 secondes contre 10 secondes la
position elle peut s'inverser à chaque
coup par contre un souffle ici avec pas
beaucoup de temps moi
j'ai du mal à voir comment les blancs
peuvent vraiment prendre l'avantage ici
non c'est pas trop grave mais c'est
compliqué pour les deux joueurs
maintenant
on voyait qu'on a vu la jauge excité le
roi qui était vraiment dans les troubles
et là c'est c'est un 55 ans et il y a
quand même le temps il faut jouer avec
les 4 secondes il va faire plein de
petites menaces
tours peut-être je sais pas mais il faut
jouer vite en tout cas il faut qu'il
garde ses 30 secondes d'avance si garde
ses 30 secondes d'avance il peut la
coller
alors Sarine n'est pas entraîné par
rameche
[Musique]
c'est pas Google
c'est une autre école
comme on avait prévu
ouais c'est bizarre qu'il est pas joué
un tout petit peu plus vite pour garder
après ce temps parce qu'il a joué très
naturel
[Musique]
je ne pourrai pas te dire mais je sais
que c'est pas un match
il me semble qu'il est pas de chez Nike
comme tous les autres
mais peut-être
en tout cas à l'époque il était pas
ensemble après peut-être qu'il a du coup
changé
avec un pull et un manteau
bah écoute chez moi il fait combien il
doit faire une quinzaine de degrés et
chez toi
il doit faire à peu près à 20 degrés
mais c'est
une veste c'est une veste c'est une
sorte de pull en fait
c'est pas un manteau c'est pour piéger
les gens
c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est un
peu ça me fait plaisir de c'est pas tous
les jours qu'on peut piéger Bogo Luke
bof donc je suis plutôt je suis plutôt
content de moi le piège était tendu
elle est d'accord
voilà donc ce qui était changé par pièce
comme elle faire du coup
ok du coup bon petit pouce blanc avec
l'option aussi
on va travailler avec naze
c'était un plan aussi très important
les Noirs vont finir par un jeu de 5 ans
histoire mais c'est bizarre la position
des pièces chez Annie gigieri
j'aimais bien sa position il y a deux
trois coups il joue très vite et
maintenant il va laisser le pion ici
filet bien sûr c'est la faiblesse puis
arriéré sur colonne semi-ouvertes
sur le répertoire blanc
qu'il a pas des bonnes positions après
l'ouverture avec les moyens on sait pas
trop pourquoi le cavalier en B3
on peut le prédire
allez ce qui va me faire mentir un petit
E5 stuff ou pas
un cavalier
donc
des fois il y a des coups de consolides
avec B6 qui existent mais bon après
quand je vais ouvrir il y aura peut-être
des fous prend B6 à un moment donc c'est
plus logique de le faire maintenant je
pense
[Musique]
pas de cavaliers pas de fou
au sein dans les meilleures conditions
possibles et il a raison parce qu'au
final les blancs peuvent pas empêcher du
du tout 5 il y a pas de fouet F4 il y a
rien pour empêcher et d'ailleurs
je pense que à Nice je vois qu'il s'est
un peu trompé il se prépare déjà à la
rupture heureuse 5 adverse dame D1 c'est
pourquoi alors je sais pas trop
c'est bizarre j'arrive pas à comprendre
l'idée
[Musique]
je comprends mieux il se dit bon
vraiment il y a aucun cours donc je lui
laisse je prépare j'ai comme tu l'as dit
tout à l'heure 5 après puis on prend le
pion il est pas en prison cavalier mais
c'est une cible alors que avant c'était
pas une cible donc du coup bon à voir
mais en tout cas le noir ils ont réussi
leur ouverture c'est clair parce que
ils ont un dynamisme plus important ce
qui est rare donc là tu peux manger mais
tu poses une femme manger peut-être d'un
coup
pour venir un peu sur les cases blanches
taper un peu ces faiblesses là voilà
c'est la partie et ça reste solide chez
les Blancs quand même donc
se retourner
de voir que j'arrive à deviner les coups
de guéri toi qui a parié sur Sarine dans
un match bah oui ça me fait surtout
plaisir qu'il soit revenu à 3 2 qui sont
en avance au temps mais la position je
la trouve je la trouve casse gueule
qu'on peut jouer dans cette position
mais bon c'est bien que dans ce genre de
position on a deux choix soit attendre
soit y aller c'est pas facile je vais
juste 4 soufflent mais il y a peut-être
des problèmes qui avaler prend E5 et F4
ça peut arriver aussi
il y a des faux F2 derrière je sais pas
c'est très compliqué
mais je suis même pas sûr que ça gère le
problème quoi donc
il est revenu faire ça quand même
c'est ça
[Musique]
de prendre plein de cartes
au final il sait quand même pas mal
affaibli la structure
mais ça lui a coûté du temps de jouer
faux 4 et je comprends qu'il soit pas
sûr parce que
c'est le premier coup qu'on a envie de
jouer mais c'est très complexe pourquoi
parce que déjà cavalier prend un 5 qui
existe sur cavalier prend un 5 qui
protège C6
généralement
on préfère plutôt se laisser prendre
pour ramener les pièces en défense on
peut aussi
mais maintenant peut-être sauf il y a la
menace de C5 quand même parce qu'on a
installé enfin menace et menace relative
le foot
qui existe
[Musique]
encore une fois il peut arriver
et donc elle change tu vois guéri tâche
des jugé il a pas la jauge tu as vu la
claque à la prise dès qu'il dégage
pourtant pourtant je l'avais dit de ne
pas manger le 5 qu'il fallait plutôt
mettre de l'attention
Aniche et t'as pas écouté ce stuff bah
tu vas voir là bon on sait que c'est
parti perdu maintenant
si un seul moment
perdu
je crois
mais F3
il va se passer quelque chose peut-être
parce que
une sorte de
une batterie je suis fatigué
et du coup
le cavalier et de matière en fait ça la
menace
G4 ça peut exister
c'est peut-être assez fort
e
c'est bon ça c'est une belle team et on
voit caniche et tout là ils sont au bord
du gouffle dès maintenant juste un je
prends
et sur F3 du coup tu veux faire damage
de avec c'est bien ça en plus surprise
et dames G3 je menace maths ici et mat
ici c'est ça alors il y a que relief 3
ouais
[Musique]
sur dame G3 incroyable dès que tu lui
souffles leboncoin l'améliore
tout en prise il y a tout emprise à mes
tactiquement Sarine il est il est
vraiment là il est vraiment là c'est
quand même deux fois quand même avec les
Blancs que Guy ce matin
aurait pu lui faire du
Malfa on peut imaginer
on a vraiment du matos en moi mais il y
a des maths de partout
il y a pas de changement
allez bravo
c'est parti ah ça on est sur une un
début col du cartor j'aime bien
intéressant un petit début un voyage il
nous passe en revue tous les petits
débuts il y a pas de grosse prise de
risque dans les débuts
avait quand même vraiment bien débuté à
son match j'étais dominant on pouvait
craindre d'ailleurs pour une petite
raclée en fait pas du tout ni les
revenus et maintenant c'est un match qui
stannonce tendu stuff
de guéri
on sait que c'est un masque qui qui est
chaud donc
il va falloir encore plein de choses
dans ce match en tout cas je fais fureur
avec ma doudoune il y a Alex qui veut me
l'acheter aussi
il me le demande de façon détournée mais
il n'y a que la fourrure sur la capuche
donc mais là c'est chaud de cette veste
je vous rassure vous prenez soin de moi
dans le chat
des pièces
[Musique]
aussi
connu ce type de plan ça apparaît c'est
plus logique effectivement de la mettre
en A8 de copier en plus
on a les pièces
sont assez côté blanc aussi
que peut toujours rebondir sur B50 à 5
retour des cavaliers sans doute là
histoire de d'activer la pièce qui ne
joue pas ça a l'air vraiment logique
il y a des B4 aussi mais est-ce que ici
ça apporte quelque chose
de savoir ce que vraiment ça a l'air
vraiment logique pour ticker le cavalier
gagner la case 5 pour le cavalier F3
voilà
il faut le cacher peut-être cavalier 3e
je peux pas il y a B5 faut que je fasse
attention quand même tactique tiens je
prends on reprend je fais échelle j'ai
envie de Madame
ça ça peut avoir un [ __ ] faut faire
attention
[Musique]
alors comment cavalier ce5
comment j'améliore cette position
améliorer les pièces ici
il y a
B4 comment je peux faire pour améliorer
encore
on va le regarder après Aniche il a joué
à Nice guéri en 20 secondes pour
l'instant
et souvent on a dit que c'était la bonne
idée je vais vite mettre la pression
autant
en fait on voit que la position de des
deux joueurs est assez agréable
mais c'est pas facile de trouver une
idée pour les blancs tours c'est un
alors il laisse faire
confiance
au sacrifice de France que là dans cette
config après cavalier 4 on peut
simplement revenir en G1 que moins
inquiet
et preuve de droit prime de 4 moi j'ai
un pas grand chose effectivement mais la
tour qui pourrait coulisser à n'importe
quel moment quand on sait on voit qu'il
était en panne d'inspiration quand même
je me pose un coup ou pas
allez le rêve sans que tu te fâches
mais ça fait penser une partie une fois
que j'ai joué j'ai joué un point un peu
comme ça sauf et il y a un ami qui est
passé grand maître de puits il m'a dit
qu'est-ce que c'était que ce coup de
merde Kevin quand voilà après la partie
et j'ai regardé c'est le premier coup de
l'ordinateur quoi mais bon
sur le moment je savais pas quoi donc je
l'ai découvert qu'après quoi si j'avais
su
pas
normalement si vous voulez on fait les
attaques quand le centre est stable ce
qui est rigolo dans le coup de stouf
c'est qu'il le fait alors le centre et
ouvert mais il est stabilisé plus ou
moins par le cavalier E4 voilà donc
c'était un essai
et c'est c'est assez chaud en vrai en
tout cas il est pas du tout d'accord
avec son poulain Aniche qui joue pas du
tout comme ça lui il fait des trucs
beaucoup plus tranquillou pépère le
micro sur zoom pour qu'il puisse
m'entendre parce que j'ai 5 j'ai 5 en
vrai en pratique ça avait l'air
intéressant quand même sur un sur un
mustwin
sauf que là on va on s'attend plutôt à
une partie un peu soporifique
c'est moins rigolo là très technique
[Musique]
c'est une petite un petit pic parce que
la dernière fois j'avais un petit bug
lors du premier
speechestre que j'ai commencé cette
année et j'ai voulu partager l'écran sur
Google meet à maths je l'ai partagé sur
le zoom avec avec aaronian avec tout ça
et je me suis trompé de fenêtre mais
j'avais j'avais tellement de fenêtre
ouverte j'avais discord j'avais Google
meet deux fois et j'avais
et j'avais
les zoom c'est un petit peu un petit peu
compliqué bon maintenant qui commence à
prendre un petit peu d'espace ici
il y a pas grand chose mais bon là ce
qui m'inquiète c'est de jouer une contre
3 il y a pas besoin là il faut qu'ils se
il faut qu'il se bouge NiAl
c'est 5 voilà surtout que c'est des quoi
assez facile ça pour lui
il prend pas de risque il fait nul et on
voit la partie d'après quoi il faut
qu'il joue vite mais tu vois je commence
à allumer de plus en plus c'est noir
parce que le noir ils ont les pièces
plus au centre et puis
bon c'est égal mais si tu devais choisir
un camp je prendrai les noirs
non non je suis bien en Bretagne et
endertale qui me dit que avec ma
doudoune c'est pour
prêcher le faux et que je suis au Qatar
non c'est pas vrai je suis bien en
France je suis bien proche de Rennes
voilà c'est le meilleur ambulette
normalement on y a le Sarine parce que
c'est son métier quasiment mais à Nice
guéri on a vu qu'il était pas pataud du
tout sauf nous a annoncé un lot à plus
de 3200
Bullet et Bullet parce que là c'est
quand même un peu différent que du 1 + 0
il y a pas de Flag enfin il y a du flag
mais c'est pas pareil quoi
pour fixer un peu le pion en G2 et H3
pour après éventuellement pouvoir
attaquer le pion en G2 c'est hésiter
intéressantes mais très des menaces
voilà
il doit être voilà un petit peu un petit
peu gêné dans cette position
de pas trop trop
minutes 50
ils ont deux minutes 45
une ou deux parties à cette cadence se
trouve donc ça a décidé du 7 je rappelle
qu'il y a deux
accepter
voilà c'est marrant
c'est quand même mieux autant
est-ce que tu en avais vu d'autres
souffles dans tes commentaires
pas plus que ça généralement ça joue en
célébrités
de jouer mais il est connu que dans ce
cas là on met le fou en F4
bon c'est des choses qu'on connaît
normalement on joue avec G4 H4 ce genre
de position un G4 normalement c'est des
cours classiques ici
dans cette config normalement il y a une
config mais le Fou est en E7 à la place
de du petit coup à chiasse et en fait
j'ai 4 donc là je vois pas pourquoi je
le ferai pas
et bon bah jugé
mais bon c'est ton poulain moi je vais
lui donner un bon coup il écoute pas
tant pis il y a eu ces 4 G5 il a pas
respecté tout à l'heure aussi donc si
hyper il sera où sont ses erreurs
un peu soporifique pour après prendre
les blancs
[Musique]
les plans classiques ici comme il y a
une pièce mineure d'échanger
peut-être qu'il va passer plutôt par
tourbé un B4 mais c'est quand même le
foot casse blanche qui a été changé donc
ça laisse la case C4 il y a un plan
chinois sur l'attaque de minorité qui
est de jouer B5 cavalier B6
très connu aussi voilà pour la case C4
donc là il est pas il a l'air parti pour
F3 E4 effectivement comme comme tu le
pressentais sauf que tout a D1 n'indique
pas l'attaque de minorités
5 qui arrive enfin dès qu'on peut est-ce
qu'on peut jouer ces 5 là il y a le pion
des 5 c'est pour ça qu'il a il a joué
touradé en prévision
mais ok des fois il y a ces cinq ans
même c'est toujours compliqué en gros
casser un petit peu les cases noires ici
ouvrir la position et profiter un peu de
l'ovation du roi avec F3 mais il y a le
problème du pion des 5 quand même
des seins qui peut être pris et c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que du coup il a fait
tourner un avant pour attaquer les 5
pour défendre aussi des cadres pour
vraiment centraliser les pièces avant
l'ouverture de la colonne parce que là
le plan blanc c'est E4 et après si on
les Noirs la sphère E5 et après on
balancerait tout avec F4 F5 dans le
futur ça se passe jamais comme ça sauf
un niveau amateur quelquefois où les
Noirs laissent tout faire mais sinon sur
E4 faudra absolument prendre 4 ou alors
je vois le contre-jour avec ces 5
maintenant
je suis certain que c'est ce que calcule
NiAl et d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il a fait
jouer c'est et du coup vous avez vu la
jauge prendre il était pas sûr parce que
il y a le pion D5 en l'air et c'était la
stratégie de ah oui c'était pas ça ça a
l'air de pourtant d'être bien et Dame
des deux ici Dame des deux meilleurs que
dame Descartes je pense à cause de
cavaliers E6 voilà bon c'était la ligne
qui paraissait normale et maintenant que
fait NiAl qu'est-ce qu'il a prévu ici
attendez à cela
et maintenant parce que moi j'étais
arrivé là je savais pas quoi faire ok
d'accord donc là aussi mais on peut même
prendre en dessin tout et je savais pas
ce que donner cette position j'avais
peur de donner les pions
ce que je peux manger
[Musique]
j'aime beaucoup ton coup et d'ailleurs
Aniche la jouer donc là ça sent pas bon
pour nous avec NiAl si on présente
beaucoup parce que tu conserves
l'avantage tu vis voilà en fait je vais
manger le pion sans perdre mon four
important parce que oui quand même
donc un peu plus affaiblis vu que je
joue F3 donc si je perdais vous ça
pourrait être quand même une
une enfin il y aurait du contrôle au jeu
quoi en fait pour le pion
c'est une très bonne position ici pour
pour les blancs parce qu'il y a toujours
fou pour un F6 en plus sur n'importe
quelle variante il peut amener le gain
du pion des 5 en plus mais peut-être
qu'on va pas avoir besoin de faut
prendre F6 qui nous permettrait de
gagner garder le foot 15 noire donc je
suis vraiment vraiment content ici avec
les Blancs et plus une minute à la
pendule
c'est peut-être une partie à deux subsa
sauf en plus
c'est peut-être la dernière partie où
non je pense qu'il va quand même une
dernière je pense encore je pense aussi
mais on sait pas si ça va si ça va au
bout et qui joue une longue finale
ouais tu as raison normalement quand
même
normalement il y en a une autre
mais on pense une partie après ça je
pense parce que là il est en difficulté
NiAl et il va être vite mal au temps et
c'est une position où les blancs peuvent
garder un avantage au temps donc la 3 et
le pion de 5 maintenant est perdu
cavaler
dans quelles conditions je vais le
redonner
et ça va être un peu avant
en fait ce qui se passe en cas d'égalité
sur le 7
c'est jamais arrivé mais oui c'est ça
incroyable je te laisserai même pas un
substance
direct
[Rires]
en plus à chaque fois tu as vu c'est
serré tu me fais espérer tu vois la NiAl
il a fait beaucoup d'efforts pour
revenir à trois
peut-être qu'il fallait attendre encore
sauf avant de prendre ce pion toi
attendu je pense toi tu aurais été
patients
MP3 donc c'est le pion de plus mais
maintenant il y a la colonne vertes
aussi intéressant
il est resté en vie au niveau du temps
NiAl même s'il va très très vite bon
c'est bien de d'être comme pas trop loin
parce que il joue une sacrée bête en
face
donc là très très intéressant
aléniable c'est le moment c'est le
moment de sortir le grand jeu
donc là ça va quelle pièce je vais
lancer 5 malheureusement la cohabitation
ça marche pas aux échecs il faut choisir
ok donc pression là dessus
je pense pas qu'il joue la nuit je pense
pas qu'il va revenir ici pour répéter
là je peux voir un petit
jamais il va faire nul ici le tour des 7
c'est pas mal
maintenant qu'il y avait plus le
cavalier ce 5
donc ces trois j'aime bien aussi l'idée
pour revenir à Marseille
en difficulté légère
[Musique]
la dynamique je crois qu'il est malade
parce que moi j'ai le zoom
il entend tout ce qui se passe
non ça c'est une meilleure tête pour
faire nul
ouais c'est intéressant
[Musique]
je commence à aimer les Noirs en fait
parce que je récupère le pion et je peux
m'activer à ça
il a perdu le fil ça se voit au niveau
du temps regardez hein maintenant
il a complètement mangé sa pendule parce
qu'il cherchait à valoriser son avantage
et là il va simplement sans doute
égaliser la position
des deux
et pousser un peu le pion etc
et changer les pièces et peut-être faire
mieux je pense que ici
aucun des joueurs en fait ne peut
vraiment jouer pour gagner parce que
[Musique]
et puis je peux pousser le pion encore
et pousser
je pense pas que il y a une danger amis
pour les produits pour les noirs
pour casser l'initiative donc ça c'est
le jeu et à la fin il mange là
donc on va revenir à nos moutons
donc
ça va faire mieux et ça joue pour les
noirs
s'il peut mettre le roi ici il peut il
peut essayer
du Tour pour dessin qui peut arriver
aussi un jour je la sens bien pour se la
faire coller celle-là pour les deux
sables il va pas me la manquer mais
c'est pas clair là même les noirs
et Pam la peau de banane quoi attention
autant il y a le dépêche-toi pas de
blague
mais on n'a pas avancé
et comment on va faire là il y en a 11
secondes on va peut-être
[Musique]
prise
un pion qui peut filer quand même un
jour hein
voilà c'était j'ai senti à arriver quoi
c'est pas vrai
oh là là là là là
là là
c'est très compliqué ce qui se passe ici
prise tout ici va récupérer le pion il
devrait pas la perdre déjà celle-là
ça a été chaud là mais il peut peut-être
jouer pour gagner cette fois
pourtant j'étais pas très convaincu par
le début je pense pas qu'il puisse
chrono
[Musique]
en plus
allez allez allez allez on pousse son
pion
allez attention on joue on joue on joue
les gars
oui elle
est oui
engager
un stop de gagner et à un moment je
faisais quand même pas le fier
la partie là tu étais foutue
de cette partie c'était la nul vous avez
vu que NiAl il a voulu continuer comme
un furieux qui s'est retrouvé foutu et
qu'en fait après avec la magie du Bullet
ça c'est complètement inversé je dis la
magie du Bullet évidemment parce que ça
a bien tourné pour NiAl sinon j'aurais
dit que c'était c'était l'horreur en
tout cas c'est très très joli
en tout cas
on fait une petite nulle pour deux sœurs
[Musique]
quand même parce que j'ai quand même
perdu une partie gagnante quoi
donc
ils sont plus sens que moi quand même on
met la vous avez vu quand même la petite
technique de stouf qui dit à son poulain
vas-y abandonne vite s'il te plaît pour
qu'on puisse rematcher
il est vraiment à la rue là j'ai
l'impression que il y a eu quand même
une baisse de régime rappelons que que
Aniche menait 3-1 tout fin il vient de
prendre 3,5 05 c'est pas top allez NiAl
aligné après la pause tu as vu un peu
souple la pause a fait du mal
comme d'hab
je suis d'accord avec toi
et on va soutenir on va soutenir à Nice
est très partisan de la victoire de
Daniel
et du coup alors ça donne quoi bah ça
donne une petite ouverture encore on a
assisté une sorte de début jobava pour
pour NiAl qui n'a pas obtenu grand chose
on va dire dans dans cette position
ou des trois c'est quand même un peu
embêtant sauf quand je regarde parce que
si je jouais F5 je donnais la grosse
case en E5
on n'a pas envie de jouer F5 en fait
avec les Noirs parce que du coup
j'aurais la case à 5 trop cadeau pour
pouvoir les blancs peut-être un cavalier
3 j'ai pas compris où il voulait
l'amener cavalier G4 maintenant
4 avant cela il est parti en B3 à la
pêche
fantômes dans ma 3 ou des choses comme
ça vous voyez on a des petits des petits
jeux sur le pion ou A4 à 4 à 5 peut-être
stof ici
j'ai l'impression que NiAl il est bien
dans son dans son rythme-là
mais A4 c'est dans l'esprit je pense de
la position tu m'as trop il y a
effectivement cavalier B5 est-ce que tu
savais Kevin que Annie je dirige le
joueur favori de notre ami Pierre Barbot
je ne savais pas on en apprend toujours
des belles finalement Damas 3 est arrivé
là jauge je ne sais pas enflammé il y
avait à 4 à 5 sans doute c'était dommage
c'est bizarre qu'il est pas joué ça
peut-être
et attendre un petit peu différent
mais bon faut pas se prendre
elle était pas mal celle-là celle-là
Néandertal gratuite pour l'ami Pierrot
bon dans ma carte il y a un pressing
quand même
parce qu'après je menace fous prends ces
7 Adam B4 je pensais que je menais A4
faut prendre ces 7 stuff pour l'option à
je sais pas
en fait
c'est vrai qui est bizarre au final
comment je peux il est en train de
travailler
vite dans la lignée il y a pas fou prend
B5 là c'est prendre B5 c'est limite
histoire on prend B5 c'est prendre des 5
fous et 7 c'est un pion
et il y va direct
et voilà nia les super
quelle équipe quelle équipe
de mauvais jours après après vous pensez
cette
par rapport à ce qu'il a livré depuis le
départ
bon remarque NiAl dans la partie
précédente il a fait exactement le même
type de début un peu modeste et il a
réussi à s'en sortir on sait que Aniche
a de grosses ressources mais la pause
lui a fait du mal franchement il fait 3
c'était quand même assez propre
particulièrement le 2-0 il avait
commencé enfin phare et là il s'est
quand même bien éteint l'ami à niche
c'est pas pour me déplaire mais il va
revenir comme comme tous mais il a un
monde moins bien
un petit kfc2 on vient E7 oui où je peux
mettre mon cavalier cavalier F1 où je
vais le mettre
en plus il y a la petite avance au temps
donc est-ce que je vais aller mettre mon
cavalier en B5 c'est bizarre
pas si facile à convertir il y a encore
du taf il est nettement mieux
qu'on ferait B3 C4 quelque chose comme
ça K4 alors c'est le couper avec les
idées cavaliers
il y a le four en l'air et c'est une roi
sur une case blanche pour défendre il y
a une découverte donc ça fait pas
beaucoup de bonnes découvertes mais ça
fait peur quand même
faut pas oublier l'arrivée de la tour en
G3 ou en E7 donc je sens que c'est
rigolo tu fais ça je reviens et puis
et puis la nuit quand même dans ce genre
de configuration on peut peut-être faire
cavalier F5 suivi de tout recettes il y
aura beaucoup de pièces sur le roi allez
là
on va prendre les deux points
j'aime bien faire la course en tête que
pour la fin du mois est-ce que tu veux
prendre les les deux points tout en
laissant du contre-jour comme ça et
peut-être de plus gagner le 7 qui avait
le F5
en tout cas ça fait peur ça fait peur
ça fait peur il ajoute tout racheter
c'est bizarre mais bon après il est sous
pression du temps c'est difficile
et pourquoi la jauge est autant excité
il doit y avoir
des 5 suivis de tout recettes il y a
dame ranger 6
ou intéressant regardez 5 c'est fou
prends il y a échec Gall Adam
si elle en prend et surtout reprend j'ai
tout recettes hyper joli de la partie
cabine aussi j'ai vu il va trouver
agneal si tu me fais ça à moi alors que
j'ai trouvé tu as deux vins c'est pas
possible que tu ne trouves pas
vu pourquoi on est partenaire d'équipes
alors que NiAl tu vois elle trouve tout
de toute façon quand il boude un projet
6 échec parce que le foot sera cloué par
la tour vous voyez c'est extrêmement
fort
c'est nickel et puis ce qui est bien
c'est que il me laisse proposer les
coups avant il est vraiment nickel NiAl
merci alors on a demandé hier sur le
stream quand j'étais avec robinside si
on avait déjà vu des remontada un peu de
l'espace ah bah oui bah écoute bah là il
y avait trois pour guéri et il perd le 7
au final 5 et demi 3 et demi je pense
que c'est quand même une belle remontage
[Musique]
tu m'as fait une belle il y a eu tu vois
des des beaux des belles choses à ce
niveau là il me semble
même le premier match avec Éric izi
qu'on voit gagner finalement il s'est
fait dégommer après enfin
il y a jamais vraiment eu plus de points
d'écart quoi là c'était euh
tranche c'était le plus faible entre
guillemets ou celui qui avait le moins
de points qui se faisait revenir dessus
donc
c'est un projet
6nel parce que franchement
et là je suis sûr qu'il va se refaire
parce que là c'était mauvais par rapport
à son niveau là la fin pour Aniche je
suis sûr qu'il va revenir hyper fort
quoi c'est là où ils sont énormes quoi
en tout cas aguerri tu as raison plus
plus à s'accélère plus l'effort mais je
trouve guéri tout à l'heure il a montré
qu'il était impressionnant qu'il jouait
très très rapidement
il y a deux points c'est pas fini c'est
pas fini du tout
donc on va voir un peu ce qui va se
passer en tout cas donc on fait une
petite pause de 5 minutes et puis on
revient ben juste après la pub donc 5
minutes tranquille petite pause reste
sur la chaîne ne bougez pas c'est le
fait de se faire le ping je t'ai pas dit
bonjour et à tous et du coup ben ne
bougez pas on revient dans un instant à
tout de suite salut
[Musique]
et nous sommes de retour alors que le 3
plus va démarrer
dans un instant ça fait du bien c'est
deux sobres de prix sur la phase en une
heure et demie souffre franchement
soulagement pour moi parce que je me
voyais bien me la faire coller direct
quand j'ai vu que ça démarrait à deux
R31 je disais que ça pouvait être long
ce stream parce que je sais que quand il
y a un écart significatif c'est quand
même plus long
significatif en la faveur de NiAl je
verrai pas le temps passer je pense
donc on va éviter
[Rires]
franchement cette position finale est
très très belle hein
donc là ça va reprendre et on change de
cadence on passe en 3 + 5 une heure de
trois plus un
des joueurs ont repris la partie et chez
moi j'ai pas j'ai encore un bug
d'échiquier comme tout à l'heure ok ben
on s'inquiète pas
je vais relancer un autre
regardez PAM et voilà
magique
c'est bizarre parce que tu vois les
joueurs jouent et moi je suis censé
avoir les chéquiers qui est connecté à
eux et voilà bon en tout cas c'est fait
c'est dans signe est-ce qu'il y a une
préparation de sur la carrocane de
Danish on a vu rester à l'écran pendant
un moment
c'est pas impossible c'est position là
je les aime bien pour les blancs plutôt
mais tout à l'heure ça a très mal tourné
ça avait posé problème
je pense qu'il a je pense qu'il a
regardé
un truc
parce qu'il avait fait un truc avant il
a fait un truc comme ça comme ça et
du coup ils souvenait plus trop on a
l'impression que là maintenant il a donc
en fait je pense qu'il s'est rappelé B3
pour moi c'est pas très naturel de le
jouer donc je pense qu'il s'en est
rappelé tout à l'heure mais au mauvais
moment et du coup il a fait un truc un
peu bizarre oui bon après avec les
Blancs on peut tous permettre en tout
cas il était il était quand même pas
très convaincu de ce qu'il avait réalisé
bon et maintenant pour quelle structure
on joue parce que j'ai pas envie de tout
prendre en E5 avec mon Rouen 8 ok il
faut ça c'est normal et attention là
attention pion aussi si on avait dit
qu'il fallait mettre pression dessus
faut F1 sans doute là
et il faut pas que tu mettrais pression
fous des trois aussi peut-être parce que
fout des trois ça pose un petit problème
on a le pion ici on a bravo c'est tout
intermédiaire bien sûr c'est pour ça que
c'est très précis ton coup au fou des
trois
voilà c'est clair avantage il est pas il
est pas sorti de l'ouverture pas sûr
qu'il répète cette ligne d'ailleurs
c'était une grande réussite cette ligne
là c'est une belle poubelle structure
d'option complètement dommage et
4 là
pour éviter G5 qui est arrivé j'étais
pas sûr
qu'est-ce que je vais faire maintenant
avec ma poubelle
donc là il faut peut-être un grand
cavalier
il doit être en train de regarder un
petit rock mais on peut pas donner le
pion le pion de retard va être trop
important
il a pas passé l'ouverture niale
n'a pas bossé pour rien il a juste
regardé ça sans doute il a pas eu le
temps de regarder plein de trucs
il a une forme de plus le temps avec les
Noirs
qu'il avait un problème
et il a checké ça je pense pendant la
pause et du coup maintenant bah on le
voit direct que ça régnait est en grave
difficulté
[Musique]
un peu surprises NiAl mais là il doit
pas être très satisfait bon ok de toute
façon c'est les noirs aux échecs c'est
plus difficile contre 4 faut faire
attention ça peut vite mal tourner on
voit on voit l'exemple
de la poubelle
vous êtes vraiment surtout contre un
joueur de la trempe d'anis guéri on a
plus rien à jouer là avec les Noirs
c'est très dur de trouver des coups
parce que lui bouge pas parce qu'il
pleut
Dame des trois on attaque le pion G6 et
comme ça
voilà sauf tranquille on améliore les
pièces et on fait mal à l'adversaire
Dame des trois jouets tour de Tours très
naturel une bonne prise de temps 24
secondes contre 2 minutes
pour deux va être joué vraisemblablement
pour améliorer les pièces suivi de tout
un tranquille pas besoin de se presser
voilà tour 2 G5 H3 peut-être l'histoire
de contrôler le contre jeu avec un
balayage de kg 4 à terme Tourer
pour pour donner 0 contre jeu
l'adversaire tout à fait
plus le groupe professionnel
on préfère prendre G4 qui ne changent
pas tout de la position que 5 qui est
quand même le point noir de la position
de la position des noirs issus de la
carrocane là on est on est quand même
vraiment vraiment embêté et là il
travaille aussi voilà faut c'est ça très
joli que j'avais pas vu et maintenant
le pion va tomber
cavalier F7 ça peut manger du coup il
regarde les pièces pour essayer
d'arnaquer parce que cette position avec
le temps
et regarder maintenant ni à laisser
d'envoyer des clics à n'importe où sur
l'échiquier il va essayer de cliquer
partout
pour donner
il a donné le
pion fait un gros boulot il est venu
chez jaloux de son cavalier et propose
l'échange très malin et voilà il a
disparu faire tant d'effort pour ça
c'est 5 derrière mais 11 secondes contre
40 il faut poser des problèmes pratiques
pour revenir au temps échec avec avec la
propriété
où il veut là Aniche il n'y a pas une
pâte dame 3 dame 7 par exemple
tranquille
il doit le regretter mais il est quand
même tellement bien niche il peut tous
permettre
mais faut faire gaffe en face vous avez
quand même un joueur qui est très très
opportuniste
très très vite
c'est pas très convaincant ce qu'a fait
il a laissé de l'espoir Ania la tension
c'est le speechasse on sait que ça peut
tourner il faut pas jouer il faut pas
jouer le temps tu sais que le temps là
ça m'a ça marche pas il y a un
imprégoire
c'est vraiment compliqué
c'est ce qui fait
et maintenant
je pense
il doit pas être content lyrics
incroyable
ah c'est nul maintenant on ferait pas de
l'opposition partout
pas de bêtises NiAl c'est très bien
annule le beau demi point sauvé par Anya
parce que la partie était d'une grande
grande maîtrise à Nice
peut-être la seule petite bêtise qu'il a
fait parce que ça a été incroyable ça
partie à neige guéri c'est qu'à un
moment il a été un peu lent pour finir
la partie je trouve
c'est à dire que il a pris une minute de
réflexion un moment où je regarde juste
je t'intéresse
rapidement
ça aussi et franchement si
Siri il arrive hyper prêt sur ces deux
ouvertures et ben le match peut tourner
parce que là au final la partie avant
bon il a pas gagné guéri mais bon si il
fonctionne
deux fois que son adversaire a regardé
parce que nous on a compris donc
normalement il peut aussi s'adapter il a
pas que deux petites ouvertures
elle est là l'idée de faire F4 on donne
la case mais on a les pions qui peuvent
avancer bon après c'est les positions
qui sont tendues
les positions en fait on est à content
avec les Blancs parce qu'on avec les
Noirs parce qu'on peut essayer de gagner
mettre des belles choses en place mais
on peut aussi bien se faire retourner
dans ce genre de truc où on avance tous
nos pions c'est extrêmement compliqué
déjà et ça
c'est le genre de position ou un niche
guéri un peu moins en maîtrise donc bon
il a été brillant jusque là même s'il a
pas tout gagné mais je préfère quand on
y a ce genre de position un peu bizarre
oh oui
qu'on a du mal à maîtriser justement ce
que je trouve que Annie je guéri quand
on commence à poser les pièces sur les
cases de manière
assez facile je le trouve excellent
dans les oppositions simples il est
vraiment terrible alors que là bon
alors là il y a un risque de G5 G4
pour essayer de dompter mais pas du tout
peut-être il y a F3 peut-être c'est
dangereux j'aime pas trop le roi je
devais dans
ce qui se passe en tout cas ça fait
réfléchir
il s'est pris les pièces dans la table
le dernier coup sur qu'est-ce qu'il
aurait fallu jouer alors c'est le coup
précédent
autant
au moins nous on se réparalisé complet
lui il peut toujours faire des choses
bon là quand même
on doit pas être très satisfait parce
que la position c'est vraiment obscurci
je suis là je suis en stress
il y a des problèmes camin ça arrive
dans cette partie sinon il jouerait pas
aussi lentement
et
il prend G7 alors là je prends mais il y
a aussi d'un compteur on m'a dit ouais
pour essayer de pour essayer de tenir ma
boutique et là
et sur un F3 peut-être un petit G3 pour
enlever la dame noire qui me fait très
peur
il y a des problèmes
il va falloir essayer de de calmer la
position il y a pas le choix
je pense que c'est presque la meilleure
config pour NiAl et à 254 secondes peut
peut-être espérer tirer de l'eau c'est
bizarre j'ai H5 parce que là j'ai une
tête une bonne opportunité il a
peut-être oublié cavalie F4 surtout
Rachida
il peut le matin voilà ce matin mais
est-ce que je peux faire roi j'ai un
stuff 3 G1 pour H8 non je pense que tu
reprends un chien qu'il y a cavalier F4
et mon cavalier revient
tu peux peut-être faire tout rage vite
ce roi G1 qui est très très intéressant
mais au moins je me tire des des réseaux
je comprends qu'il est pas fait le malin
avec avec un peu de temps
je pourrais peut-être jouer Roy F2 et
puis essayer de doubler après je vais
essayer de faire ça
bien sûr bien sûr je pense que c'est
peut-être pas grand chose mais quand
même c'est ce qui c'est un petit
dangereux maintenant pour les deux
joueurs
il y a un petit truc
je préfère jouer côté blanc maintenant
il fait sur Tours qu'est-ce que je rate
donc voilà jauge n'est pas largement la
faveur des blancs
cavalier F5 peut-être mais il y a tout
E5 quand même pas génial pourtant pour
les Noirs j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont
foutu mais la jauge j'ai pas trop excité
donc maintenant qu'on a l'indication ah
oui on peut jouer ah oui le matin F1 en
fait et du coup il veut faire nul comme
ça
franchement les deux
le petit matin F1 fait que on peut pas
s'investir avec toutes nos pièces
comme ça
guéri dans les parties de tour B8 avec
l'autre
faut partir avec le roi peut-être là ça
a l'air pas mal quand même pour les
noirs
mais quand même on s'est aperçu qu'à
chaque fois qu'il avait joué bah il
s'était retrouvé en grosse difficulté
quand même faut jouer là il y a plus de
temps sur trois secondes chacun
[Musique]
ils nous rendent fou ils nous rendent
fou aïe aïe c'est pas vrai il s'en est
sorti bon il mérite la victoire
honnêtement même si je supporte NiAl
salut
Arnaud comment vas-tu Arnaud
quelle est ma peine ici
ça sert à rien de gagner le 7,5 + 1 si
c'est pour perdre le match et tout le
reste c'est du
terrible pour pour NiAl bon après c'est
des parties méritait pas mais il
s'accroche bien
et vous voyez il veut tout le temps
gagner par contre là il a forcé il a
oublié quelque chose non il se dit tiens
j'ai forcé et il oublie une tactique il
était un peu moins attentif il se
pensait que l'autre lui offrait la nul
potenti potentiellement il a voulu
refuser mais en fait c'était bien joué
ce qu'il a fait à bon s'il y a pas Caval
le 4 c'est très bien joué
c'était pas facile d'ailleurs
[Musique]
stouf mine de rien dans la partie
précédente Aniche a encore trouvé une
défense alors qu'on voit qu'on va se
faire planter sur la colonne il a été
quand même avec peu de temps à la
pendule très maître de ses décisions
un petit peu en difficulté au niveau de
son zoo de pièces E4 va arriver sauf et
ça va laisser des perspectives fortes de
pression c'est pour moi
il y a un vis-à-vis avec un clouage qui
pourrait
des F4 cavaliers des 4 et du coup ça
donne pas envie alors est-ce qu'on a le
temps de faire réussir tous c'est
peut-être la question qui se pose mais
bon j'y crois pas du tout quoi j'ai pas
du tout envie de le faire
je l'aurais pas fait hein
il y a plein de raisons
ça veut dire parce que c'est ça qui a le
pion des 5
c'est la partie c'est le coup qui a été
joué
3 F2
il va vouloir F3 et G4 et cavalier tu
vois il va aller ici bien sûr la caser
F5 et là ça va commencer à faire mal
parce qu'en plus tu as toujours le lieu
de faire cavaler des quatre là aussi
c'est intéressant parce que ça force
on connaît toutes ces ruptures en plus
tout enfin F6 c'est génial
qui est prise 7
c'est très très beau la rupture ce que
vous voyez en terme de structure de pion
là c'est vraiment à une vitesse folle
l'exécution des principes de structure
c'est juste fou
parce que le centre blanc il était
gênant il a trouvé ce petit F6 petit
coup de pion tempo et d'ailleurs il
mange pas F6
[Musique]
il veut garder les colonnes ouvertes
pour avoir la case F6 alors est-ce qu'on
peut pas faire français 5 non on peut
pas
M6 peut-être qu'il y avait de ce contre
jeu de sur le pion arriéré en E3 qui a
du mal à avancer et du coup maintenant
mais en fait il veut juste garder
initiative avec F1 et prendre F6 c'est
rentrer
OK
tout est possible mais ça sera assez
galant sans doute
se passer
je suis pas ce qui me gênait c'est pour
ça que j'ai pas proposé c'est
voilà mais il a dû prévoir il a dû
dans ces variantes en prises mais ça me
fait peur tu vois un petit peu
G8 sans doute la tour G8 c'est fort
à titre perso j'avais peur de la rentrée
de la tour en F6 signal il a calculé et
ici a dit il rentre en M6 pour prendre
G6 mais j'aurais toujours G8 magnifique
encore
ah ils ont montré vraiment
pourquoi elles sont à ce niveau là en
terme de calcul ils vont plus loin et
ils sont toujours dans la critique
perpétuelle des principes généraux parce
que ces joueurs là ils sont meilleurs
aussi parce qu'ils ont des capacités de
calcul très importantes mais il bafoue
allègrement les principes généraux à
l'aide de leur calcul et du jeu de
concession c'est à dire ils sont prêts à
faire des petites concessions et
d'obtenir des choses fortes de la part
de leur adversaire c'est
il y a beaucoup de monde il y a
quasiment tous les meilleurs du monde
qui sont engagés dans ce tournoi demain
c'est la fin des huitièmes de finale
mais encore en course il y a Magnus
Carsen Fabiano cawana
vraiment tous les meilleurs tous les
meilleurs joueurs du monde c'est énorme
donc Nakamura qui terminera demain donc
on a vu un rognan là c'est guéri Niels
a gagné il reste Abdou sa torov so qui
aura lieu demain et on a Maxime va chez
Lagrave aussi qui est notre représentant
français qui a gagné qui a battude sur
un score très large il y a un peu Machi
et c'est pas pour nous déplaire non non
mvl a gagné et de façon assez large ou
là je trouve ça bien avancé
et je suis pas très
allez faut pousser Usain Bolt sans doute
mais le roi il est quand même plus actif
et
je pense que c'est dur quoi
je peux pas passer déjà et sur B2 je
vois ces deux donc peut-être un peu
on sait pas encore comment est-ce qu'il
va jouer Maxime en fait ça va dépendre
de c'est bizarre préférer regarder B3 B3
cavalier des trois cavaliers
il va faire cavalier un je pense qu'il a
prévu
quoi il a pas poussé de B3 B2
pas compris
allez allez tous les pions là alignés
dans le carré du pion allez on pousse et
puis maintenant attention il faut les
pousser
[Musique]
ça fait plaisir ce plus de
qui reprend les commandes dans ce dans
ce match et dans le 7 du coup il égalise
avec un et demi 1 et demi
ah c'est bon ça
va très bien parce que
petite partie très simple
toujours de prendre l'avantage autant
dans l'ouverture en tout cas lyrisme
extrêmement vite bon ça c'est assez
connu NiAl bon c6c5 c'est moins connu
mais si on met le fond des trois directs
avec C5 C3 sera assez logique CD on met
le cavale et en B3 bon bah merci signal
dame de ok bon bah j'espère que
alors
ça reste stable
le mode tortue ornial et on joue très
vite attention à la menace cavalier F4
parce que il y a B5
pourquoi parce que le coup d'âme 3 est
pas très esthétique devant le fousser
tout ça mais il arrive justement à jouer
ses coups moches à reculons et les joues
en quelques secondes c'est assez
déroutant pour son adversaire
que c'est sûr qu'il y a pas grand chose
là pour vu la tête de la position
blanche il y a rien du tout
continue avec les avec les noirs qui
avaient les quatre fois sûrement faut
pas se faire enfermer avec fasciste ouf
j'ai pas envie de me prendre la tactique
de l'année
comme ça parce que j'ai l'impression que
ça se retourne là sur un roi G7
peut-être
bouger mon cahier des deux pour réitérer
si vous voulez maintenant c'est le
cavalier F4 qui est cloué
c'est compliqué ça est-ce que
c'est exactement ça le cloche qui se
transforme en découvert sous la
découverte qui se transforme en cloage
c'est un classique du genre le cloueur
il a perdu une bataille mais pas encore
là la guerre de cette
reconnaître nos erreurs et de et de
revenir à la maison tranquille et ça
fait quand même mal à l'ego pour pour
niche qui s'est trompé
et E5 le 5 très intéressant sauf pour
bloquer un peu le centre et peut-être
qu'on pourrait voir un classique dammeka
damage 4 alors faut faire attention pion
E5 j'aurais bien A4 pour faire carrer sa
carte mémoire ici
après je fais mon plan de transférer mes
pièces vers les lois la fait cavalier 4
incroyable
parce que qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
histoire de laisser le Pione 5 ans prise
tu vois tu vas m'expliquer s'il te plaît
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire à
tempo quasiment en plus
plus pour les Noirs qu'est-ce que c'est
que cette daube là je comprends pas et
là je vais très vite je
suis pas qu'est-ce que j'aimerais bien
comprendre l'idée
que tu m'expliques mais en fait il y a
pas plus trompé à ce point-là quand même
pas si c'est possible tu me diras ça
arrive à tout le monde
roi géant ok bon là du coup les noirs
sont juste nuls je pense c'est clair
toi quand tu les comme fou c'est qu'à 3
G1 enfin juste tu as rien dit
j'arrive pas à vous l'expliquer
on a assisté à une sorte de petite
livraison là
de NiAl qui est pas coutumier du fait et
quand j'ai 5 ça c'est un coup bien
tricky comme il faut je pense mais je
peux tout est changé juste
tu peux ah oui tu échanges comment
kavanes
un poil attention quand même mais
peut-être un coup de cavalier ici genre
cavalier C7 parce qu'on a le droit non
il faut F4 c'est malin là ce qui fait
prévu quoi
c'est normal
et la paire de fou et
c'est quand même pas bon bizarre ce
cavalier 4 en tout cas sous forme pas du
tout convaincant
[Musique]
la paire de fou et bien joué mais ce qui
est marrant c'est que des mecs sont
super forts et ils sont Poker Face ils
font enfin c'est une méga une méga
bêtise qui a fait niale aucun face on
joue aux échecs voilà je tiens et ce
n'est pas mal sorti il est pas loin
d'être à niveau d'ailleurs dans la
partie
il y a une rentrée non cavalier aussi
c'est égal maintenant super je pense
qui rend la barre de fou d'ailleurs
sur cette partie parce que le c'était il
avait super bien joué je trouvais mais
il a craqué A4 peut-être pour faire
quelque chose voilà super bravo
ça peut être décisif pour essayer de
mettre de la pression peut-être Oursi
soignable et là dans ses positions il
est assez fort il pose des problèmes
faut trois j'aime bien avec les idées à
5 B4
je pense qu'il faut jouer ça je vois pas
trop
quoi d'autre faire parce qu'à cinq j'ai
quand même un gros problème sur la
structure et je dois faire tourner
mais il y a quand même un problème je
trouve ça je peux essayer de tout
reprendre ici trois points
n'oublie pas la pendule
qu'est-ce que tu fais la déconnexion
c'est maintenant
il a joué vraiment les coûts évident
mais la 10 secondes pour le faire G4
bravo J4
allez on passe les problèmes
pour mettre en soumission l'adversaire
le roi a podcast
je pense
il est venu en G6 pour l'instant
attendant B7
sur mon
bon ici c'est nul
je sais pas trop parce qu'en fait le roi
blanc va arriver pour moi c'est
normalement c'est archi le parce que ah
sauf si j'arrive en f5f6 un moment ah
oui non non tu as raison il y a des
petits problèmes pratiques quand même
échec
en plus
bien sûr je mange pas le pion les gars
si la Tour Noire quitte la colonne B les
blancs bougeront leur tour et
de partout normalement
ça ça fait nul facile normalement
ça va faire nul
donc tes deux joueurs
je pense qu'après c'est parti c'est la
pause il y aura pas vu
il y a eu peut-être
non non
ça va très vite dans cette position là
du coup deux deux dans ce deuxième set
avec toujours Sarine qui garde son
avance de de deux points qu'il avait
réussi à se faire dans la première
portion de 5 + 1
dirige il y a eu quand même pas mal de
d'opportunités dans ce deuxième set et
qui n'a pas réussi à transformer les
essais tout à fait donc donc voilà donc
on fait une petite pause de trois quatre
minutes et on revient dans un instant
pour le dénouement de ce deuxième set en
trois plus une à tout de suite sur le
stream à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut pas avoir accès nous sommes de
retour non malheureusement c'est fermé
l'anglais parce que
un peu tardivement et par contre
vous pouvez aller dans la rubrique
événement et reprendre reprendre la
position si ça vous intéresse et
peut imaginer quoi comme gain donc
normalement le roi pouvait peut-être se
rapprocher du pion en attaquant la tour
ce qui libérait la tour B8 c'est quelque
chose comme ça en tout cas on n'a pas vu
mais en tout cas on peut pas suivre
parce que ça va reprendre
[Musique]
le truc désolé
c'est pas mal son petit truc à anial tu
sais la petite variante avec archives
je regarderai parce que ça m'intéresse
pour jouer ça en blitz c'est pas mal je
trouve
et le Rhône en position de gagner ah oui
ok
OK
alors du coup dans ce match là toujours
deux points d'avance pour Niall Sarine
Guerry qu'elle est blanc ici
qui va essayer de la pression sur le
casque blanche peut-être
un petit cavalier F5 qui peut arriver
non pas du tout F3 E4 ok
mais cette partie quand même qu'il y
avait pas mal souris l'épisode avec C5
qui était un peu prématuré il avait
réussi à il avait réussi à avant à bien
en profiter avec les
avec les Blancs il a effet nul dans la
partie mais il avait raté des chances
pratiques
je te regardais à moi-même souffrir il y
avait un gars il fallait sacrifier le
pion B7 pour rentrer dans la finale
d'option
et du coup avec la structure figée en H5
G4 effectivement si elle est opposition
était dans le camp adverse comme on nous
l'a dit dans le dans le chat et ben ça
fait mal et stop bien joué
je vais te donner tas de pions
B8 toujours pareil la structure c'est H5
G4 F de H4
le roi noir est en G7 le roi blanc il
était en D6 tu pouvais jouer tout R8
tours en V7 tout recettes tout reprend à
trois et le roi est en G7
malheureusement et horrible quoi bon
c'est dur à avoir avec peu de temps quoi
[Musique]
les tours en plus dans ce genre de
position mais bon avec du temps ils
auraient tous les deux trouvé et ça
aurait fait nul mais bien sûr mais et
[Musique]
avec très peu de temps la pendule nous
on a rien vu et puis même eux ils
savaient
au moins tu as été curieux tu as regardé
donc c'est la voix de la progression
voilà ce qu'on va dire c'est ça a été
joué du coup on va remontre comme tout à
l'heure des idées avec prise en
charge à chaque fois dans cette position
puis on descendre c'est pas ça va me
donner envie moins envie
c'est pas impossible en plus
alors s'il prend des cinq qui va se
passer
prise pardon excuse-moi
la paire de fou et bien d'ailleurs aussi
il y a la cave à C7 et aussi la case D6
ici
ça rentre de partout comme on dit
ça fait peur quand même pour être tout à
fait franc je suis pas d'ailleurs
il y a une fourchette là une quinze
indéciste franchement ça fait peur il y
avait aussi du fou c'est ça qui peut
arriver
c'est compliqué même là genre fou c'est
ça celui de G4 et aussi une proposition
un coup qui est hyper intéressant
parce qu'elles sont fous c'est ça que je
crois en fait dame G5
et sur fulpron il veut sûrement cavaler
prend un TAC ta tour attaque B7 et plus
tard rebondir sur C5 avec un petit pion
de plus pour les blancs Sarine
pas content
trop de jeux pour les pièces adverses
après c'est dur les Noirs dans ce type
de cadence mais là Aniche lui donne une
belle occasion pour revenir juste après
la pause vous savez que des joueurs dans
ce speechasse ils ont souvent du mal à
digérer les pauses on a déjà parlé avec
stouf
je sais pas si il a fait exprès ou
c'était
plus quoi faire mais là les pièces on
parle des fois de coordination de
mobilité des pièces voyez les pièces
toutes disloquées
[Musique]
alors qu'il y avait un plus deux assez
tranquille ben là ça y est là je vois ce
dessiner quand même bon il y en a
arnaqué
dans ce match mais bon justement je
trouve qu'il le laisse revenir trop
facilement
on est en difficulté regardez le
cavalier H5 en grande difficulté
pas facile de le ramener en plus dans
dans la game
si on fait cavalier F6 l'adversaire nous
prend et après D5 donc c'est pour ça que
voilà on prend d'abord en D4 comme ça il
y a moins de centre
oui mais bon
oui en plus mais c'est surtout que il
doit pas avoir envie de trop chambouler
la position parce que Aniche est
tellement mieux qu'il voudrait gagner
sans t'en prendre deux risques oui quand
vous avez peut-être le fera déjouer
j'espère souffle
quand on a l'avantage enfin même dans
vos parties vous essayez de pas prendre
de risques et d'essayer de jouer
vraiment normalement tout doucement
changer les pièces
prenez pas de risque
pas en plat à dames pour deux tours 60
positions là vous avez un pion de plus
vous avez pas besoin de sacrifier enfin
d'échanger la dame au lieu de toi la
pollution comme ça de regagner
facilement
on peut imaginer un petit un coup comme
du style dame c'est deux
l'idée en fait c'est de jouer tour là
est là et de prendre le contrôle de la
colonne C je vais bien ça
j'ai trois trash 5 peut arriver dans le
style
c'est pas la folie la position bien sûr
mais bon les petits affaiblissement du
roi se fait plaisir sur le long terme
mais six secondes contre 26 aligné
tandem cavalier grosse décision de Niall
bizarre quand même encore c'est bizarre
mais j'ai l'impression
avec son body language il est pas là
très très content la F5 qui va arriver
parce que maintenant il a plus qu'à
aller là il y a pion
a poussé des pions et puis on va se
créer le bien passé
attention attention ce cavalier qui peut
être qui peut faire peur G5 plus de
temps il reste une seconde à Sarah
et il a eu le temps de tout pour le tout
avec un
qui pourrait faire un cavalcade
jamais hein il tombe jamais
tu aimes le poisson
pourquoi attention
[Musique]
plus fort quand même
on fait le tour j'ai peur pour les
fourchettes moi
la fourchette la foufou
allez on fait des échecs
est-ce que on peut qualifier ça de
triche manifeste il a dit que ça arrive
de tomber jamais pas mis tomber terrible
on reprend la tête dans ce set dirige
non mais là vous voyez c'est des Blitz
quand même de très très haut niveau par
contre Sarina a failli l'arnaquer encore
il était pas loin on voit qu'il est
qu'il est très fort pour ça il faut
rester
en tension pour pour année je guéri pas
facile quand même franchement pour le
battre il faut le il faut le tuer 10
fois quoi c'est ça mais à niche fait le
taf
mais là je suis pas content parce que il
nous a dit qu'il tombait jamais et
c'était une arnaque terrible
je suis une sorcière en fait c'est vrai
des trucs comme ça mais ok je pense que
c'est un peu plus fort de jouer le coup
de cavalier
voilà ils sont fatigués les joueurs
franchement faut repartir après des
blesses
à haute intensité
ok par contre faut des trois peut-être
les petites
les petites embrouilles à un moment puis
on prend des trois regarde le piège
étendu pour je sais pas dans ma chambre
de l'espace à un moment faire attention
il veut toujours surveiller le cahier
prend G5 là c'est un coup de fouiller
5 maintenant est possible
c'est ça que je peux peut-être encore
jouer foue 5 pour fermer ton fou après 6
c'est bizarre
je sais pas si je peux te chasser ton
fou je pense que de la fatigue chez les
deux joueurs je trouve qu'ils sont eu
des Blitz ça très très haute intensité
stuff
c'est pas évident
et le but
F6 c'est le coup qu'on a on n'est pas
sûr de vouloir d'avoir envie de jouer tu
vois parce que mais il veut lui piquer
et puis pour réouvrir le faux cavalier
E5 là il faut jouer sans doute
quand même il y a l'histoire sur A6 donc
mesdames tu as raison d'ailleurs c'est
jouer
j'avais oublié ce coup là j'espère que
l'avait vu
mais bon c'est une position dangereuse
pour les deux joueurs
[Musique]
voilà ça fait peur de prendre B2
peut-être on peut mais peut-être pas ou
alors la foule 5 et dame B2 mais alors
là c'est hyper dur à jouer quoi
pour retourner en haut là ça c'est
bizarre mais bon apparemment il y avait
la fourchette et puis il veut aussi
replacer ses cavaliers
la fourchette en dessin animé
j'ai pas envie de donner mon fou non
plus c'est pas simple comme pose hein
B3 un jour et rentrer que mettons en C2
tu es un seul coup
et alors là est-ce que je peux faire des
des G4 des choses comme ça pour essayer
d'aller
je sais pas trop ce que je dois faire
sur G4 ce que je dois pousser peut-être
juste
j'ai trois encore sauf en tout cas c'est
peut-être l'idée mais il y a des fois
aussi après c'est compliqué ça me Troie
donc il tend vers ce genre d'idées plus
interdiction de kssis pour cailler des
sets
4 non on peut pas
tourbé en Alger j'aime bien la position
fournir là allez c'est bien avec une
bise
en fait c'est un problème le roi il est
faible G4 qui peut arriver les pièces
sont pas encore bien développées c'est
pas mal pour les blancs en pratique
c'est peut-être c'est ce qu'on peut
jouer tout FC oui on peut le jouer ça
c'est sûr mais est-ce que ça marche à
tout moment oh là là c'est moule
j'aime bien quand tu te mets en colère
ah là là
je veux du beau jeu il me joue tout rein
c'est terrible
[Musique]
la technique de NiAl c'est de faire ce
scotcher Aniche sur skyd7 mais j'aurais
bien aimé tout FC1 plus logique dans la
position il faut jouer là il faut jouer
allez tranquille tout droit très
intéressant
il a jeté c'est quoi ces coups d'épicier
là on trouve rien là il a peur je pense
de cavaler
en tant
punaise
merci à toi et bienvenue sur le stream
ouais cool Charlemagne salut à toi bon
tu vois de bien renforcer la pose
essayer de prendre la colonne C par
contre pour ces 7 c'est vraiment un coup
de brut en défense
en fait ici généralement et je crois
du Tricker
mais très souvent et ben il est OK pour
répéter les positions on voit quand même
F4 G4 et faire la police
j'aime bien ce qu'il fait en plus là il
est il est bien autant
[Musique]
aussi oh là là regarde ça attention les
yeux pour les deux hein
qui est français c'est en français
arrive à tout le monde sauf maman
[Rires]
quasiment plus égaliser dans ce match
gris ça prenait
tout autre tournure quand même donc là
on est à 3 tu vas te marrer
on est à 3 dans ce set et toujours deux
points d'avance du coup pour guérir il
reste 10 minutes pour farine pardon il
reste 10 minutes 10 minutes dans ce set
et cette partie c'est peut-être la
dernière c'est pas sûr mais il est
possible que ce soit la dernière de ce
segment
[Musique]
c'est toujours un petit plus blanc ce
genre de position mais ce que ça suffira
pourquoi un petit plus blanc parce qu'on
a un petit pressing qui exercer à la
dame sur les pions
il a quand même rendu le pion exprès je
tourne à huit très très vite et la tour
du coup elle est un peu passive
ce que je trouve ça un petit peu bizarre
[Musique]
est-ce que vous voulez un peu pareil bon
objectivement même si tu fais full B4 il
y a pas grande menace après faut se
méfier de ces positions là en tout cas
pour des joueurs aussi techniques ça va
mais pour jouer en amateur
il faut surveiller aussi des fois les
tours
avec des cloisons faire attention il y a
plein de thèmes tactiques qui peuvent
arriver le cavalier à 5 qui calme pour
les 15% du Fou du fou ici la croix
j'aime bien peut-être un jour essayer de
jouer F3 à 4 je pensais
bien sentier puis les noirs sont pas
plus mal ici
de l'espace toujours un petit peu risqué
mais en même temps dans ce match c'est
aussi ce qu'il est qu'il a fait prendre
la tête ce côté
ambition dans son jeu NiAl mais il a
fort à faire en défense je trouve que
par mois c'est vraiment la classe au
niveau
au niveau des petits coups solides
d'amélioration
sur ce sujet là il ressemble un petit
peu à Carson
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'on joue là
je pense dans ce match par le style
ouais parce que Sarine joue pas mal de
petits trucs un petit peu douteux
et il arrive pas vraiment à prendre le
dessus exactement c'est vrai que
énormément quoi et il se bat mais c'est
impressionnant
très fort NiAl dans Bullet
ça ça se sent c'est plutôt dans la
théorie qui Morf par contre faut que ça
peut ça peut vraiment vriller au niveau
théorique dans les débuts de partie et
si il se retrouve trop foutu il arrivera
pas à faire la course derrière
juste je cherche depuis tout à l'heure
mais il y avait simplement tour à 8 OK
du coup il a amélioré nettement ses
pièces
NiAl
on va pas la donner comme ça alors j'ai
fou et chaque gant tempo
mais après il y a encore le vis-à-vis
donc je suis pas sûr de vraiment vouloir
faire ça c'est quoi ça bouge mon roi et
ensuite
il faut que je défende mes pièces quoi
il se passe pas grand chose pour le
moment mais dans ce genre de position
avec une minute chacun c'est toujours
dur et cela pour les deux joueurs il y a
toujours un petit pressing blanc quand
même au vu des faits des colonnes des
pièces un peu plus actives c'est pas
compliqué mais c'est toujours tu vois
quand tu
défends cette position pendant plusieurs
coups à un moment là tu tu peux oublier
des choses tu peux bien le travail
maintenant je vais me venger sur le pied
en baie aussi
[Musique]
toujours peut-être caresser cinq
cavaliers à 4 qui traînent mais c'est
joué très très vite
on a on est passé d'une tour passive à
Tours active est-ce qu'on peut jouer
ksc5 lanial
pour échanger un peu des pièces
tu vas quand C6 j'attaque un petit peu
tout et dès que tu échanges et fous
prends et après
génial c'est le moment de y aller ils
sont un peu en danger dans la partie je
pense qu'il va la jouer Sarine
et
ça attention il joue vite il a proposé
nul il a perturbé ça c'est
le poulain de stouffe ça se voit
et toujours pareil là NiAl il peut
prendre des risques inconsidérés on le
connaît
sur échec c'est pas mal ce qui fait mais
bon
c'est le Paolo Maldini des noirs
[Musique]
qui s'annonce une finale quand même
très avantageux
c'est pas simple encore
[Musique]
et il reste 2 minutes 47 dans ce premier
set et on est comme tout à l'heure avec
Guiri un peu d'eau au mur qui doit
essayer de gagner je crois que tu as
bien trop faire dans ce dans ce petit
match Kevin
et du coup
c'est Guy il est quand même à 3 points
de retard sur farine avant les lunettes
et les bullets c'est quand même sensé
être tu sais un peu émoussé parce que il
joue très bien mais dans les phases tu
sais critiques de d'ultra zenote de
Bullet il a été vraiment bon on y a
alors que guérisse on sent que c'est un
peu plus poussif il propose nul tout ça
il est moins serein quoi
c'est bon il est moins à l'aise sur
Internet tout ça et ça c'est ça c'est
clair il m'a fait une grosse impression
sur certains coups c'est pour ça que
c'est il est 7e mondial et un des
meilleurs joueurs du monde mais là
encore un peu comme Fabiano karmana qui
était qui était quand même critiqué par
moment pour pour son jeu en partie ultra
rapide là c'est quand même hyper
intéressant de voir ça
de voir que ce ne sont pas que des
joueurs de haut niveau ils peuvent jouer
à toutes les cadences quoi
donc il y a cavalier F4 qui avait été
joué dans c'est pas la même position
peut-être mais c'est des types de
pollution comme ça qui était pas mal par
wash Instagram
c'est que ça casse un peu la structure
des blancs aussi et bon les Noirs aussi
mais après on peut jouer à choix
dans cette position là c'est sûr que
c'est pas celle-là mais je parle juste
du thème en fait
ce thème connu aussi dans dans les
débuts de Londres avec fiancé des deux
d'ailleurs c'est tout aussi
du coup bah là il faut qu'il mange de la
pas trop trop le choix
[Musique]
il a mangé il reste plus que 30 secondes
dans ce set
ouais c'est la dernière partie ça c'est
sûr c'est
nul
la prochaine
alors un
ou alors un plan d'attaque frontal genre
G3 ou G4 j'ai trois peut-être
bon ça va pas du tout été ça la partie
il est serein et le time's up
j'espère que tu apprécies l'accent stouf
ah oui
tu peux me le refaire d'ailleurs
je suis un peu déçu
assez court un peu chaud
on est tous les deux voilà on a une
moyenne de 2400
et Kevin il est un peu plus de 2400
50 points d'écart entre les deux enfin
on a son point d'écart quasiment tous
les deux
pour passer mettre j'ai fait 6 normes
toi tu es à 5 je crois c'est vrai
[Musique]
deux fois à un point et l'autre tu vois
du coup j'ai fait la totale la poisse je
l'ai raté sur une partie une fois la
dame la dame de Niall elle va où là sur
fu G6
fuj6 tadamniale
pas fou G6 joue pas fouger si surtout je
joue pas fou G6
[Musique]
c'est pas vrai
mais ils ont joué vraiment des blits ça
haute pas voir plus vite faut que j'ai
ici ce que les deux joueurs est vraiment
plus vite quoi il a un petit peu tu vois
avec sa tête
on voit que c'est n'importe quoi
n'importe quoi les mecs là là ils ont
déconné c'est rare hein c'est rare dans
ce speed chasse qui est très qualitatif
mais là les joueurs sont fatigués et du
coup ils ont fait un une belle
merdouille comme on dit dans le dans le
jargon breton
échange les pièces
se fait se fait battre c'est bon pour y
aller tout H3 NiAl on joue vite on
essaie d'embrouiller
qu'est-ce que
son qu'est-ce que tu veux faire à part
toi je crois pas grand chose aller tout
H3 bim
aussi
et joue vite en face il essaie de mettre
un peu la pression
c'est vraiment là ce qui m'énerve c'est
que
ça explique peut-être ça défaites
mais là il va revenir pour rien il était
à + 3 NiAl avec une minute d'avance à la
pendule et la donner sa dame en un coup
on avait pas du tout prévu ça dans nos
plans je comprends pas ce qu'il fait
bon maintenant on y a la réussite à
trouver une position de forteresse
[Musique]
c'est dans ces moments là qu'on est bon
que si Annie je venais à ne pas gagner
il pleurait
la pollution à tout prix
pour même pour les joueurs de très haut
niveau c'est dur hein
résistent un petit peu
d'exfiltrer le roi de l'autre côté
après maintenant qu'on arrive là
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on le ramène
[Rires]
vous avez travaillé ce genre de plan
l'entraînement alors comment il va
trouver
en plus il avait même fait pour défendre
le pion au cas où s'il y avait un Dame
des deux
c'est très sérieux mais bon je prends un
jour où j'ai un
est-ce que je pars en B2
travail niche attention
ou tourrage sens n'était pas du tout
apprécié par l'ordinateur
et la belle nue
des deux côtés cette position c'est très
très chaud
allez un petit match nul à bien on
assure
[Musique]
et j'ai quand même te dire Kevin dans ce
match les deux dernières parties de
chaque set franchement
du perdre les deux quoi
c'est c'est
trop de poids
par des comme Robinson des personnes que
robinsight ton poisson et là j'espère
que Niane va faire le travail mais
contre le dernier niche qui a l'air
épuisé mais il est fatigué aussi il fait
quelques bêtises quand c'est mauvais
signe quand on voit beaucoup plus vite
certains co que les joueurs même si
l'ensemble des couilles voit tout
quasiment tout plus vite que nous
évidemment mais certains coûts tactiques
normalement c'est des piles électriques
les mecs et là par exemple l'histoire de
l'enferment dame en un coup qui est
ultra visible et Aniche qui qui plombe
40 secondes je trouve c'était du délire
quoi mais c'est clair ils sont fatigués
etc et tu vois dans le sens dans ce
match qui est quand même énormément de
parties raté par Guiri ou il avait un
énorme avantage ou en fait au final et
ben il se plante complet quoi tu vois et
là il avait des maths de partout il
avait une pièce de plus toi tu as une
pièce de plus dans dans la partie quand
même tu vois et il y a pas mal de rater
donc mais tu vois tout ça parce que du
coup ça rime quand même mais la pression
autant mais dans chaque partie et au
final bah tu finis par craquer quoi
nerveusement juste tu arrives plus quoi
complètement donc voilà voilà on revient
les gars d'ici trois petites minutes
pour le dénouement donc ça va être du
Bullet en une plus une pendant 30
minutes et avant d'éventuels des
partages bon il y a trois points
d'avance pour Sarine pour l'instant il y
a encore un match mais
faire retourner tu te rappelles stouf
dans tout est possible
mais bon il faut pas que je vais estimer
quand même guéri dangereux je suis bien
content qu'il ait fait nul là le
sauvetage mais il s'est fait ultra
dominé
voilà voilà on revient dans un instant à
tout de suite à tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et nous sommes de retour pour cette
dernière portion du speech
dénouement donc avec 17 pour l'instant
pour niassari on va commencer les
bullets
donc je pense que Sarine quand même
favoris en tout cas pour moi ambulette
mais bon trois points d'écart ça encore
une fois dépendre de la forme et de la
fatigue un peu ce qui se passe dans ce
match c'est
pas encore terminé il est motivé quand
même un guéri il est là il s'est un peu
refait il avait les yeux fatigués mais
il a bossé pendant la pause
au delà d'être d'excellents joueurs
d'échec c'est des ultra compétiteurs
chacun leur manière hein
NiAl fidèle à lui-même il bouge beaucoup
il peut jouer debout quasiment même
quand il est en partie Blitz partir
rapide il est il est parti
cette partie du coup alors les gars j'ai
une proposition enfin j'ai une question
à vous poser dans le chat est-ce que
vous préférez voir cette vue là la vue
normale où est-ce que vous préférez du
coup qu'on vous mette la vue
celle-ci
là vous voyez plus les joueurs
souvent pour le 1 0
vous les voyez en plus grand les
émotions tout ça dites moi ce que vous
préférez si vous préférez nous voir nous
et tout le monde en petit ou cadrage de
stuff
en plus
c'est franchement très très fatiguée
très très fatigué par rapport à
d'habitude alors je vais tout le monde
pense enfin on préfère celle-là j'ai
l'impression
[Musique]
vous avez vu tout le monde déjà pendant
le 5 + 5 + 1
Rania elle est très très gentil
on peut vous dire extrêmement gentil
il est plutôt plutôt petit il y a et du
coup il fait moins peur
dans ce cas pour une partie qui va sans
doute tendre vers vers l'égalité mais
avec 30 secondes chacun il peut tous
passer on va planquer le roi je suis
tout G8 peut-être
bon on préfère avoir le tandem cavalier
dans ce style de position
NiAl joue ça je pour l'instant 30
secondes chacun il est pas lent
le sabligue préférait la première
vous êtes perdu sur ma tête
[Musique]
donc pour ces quatre tours
je trouve que il a été très très
intéressant dans son choix ici à niche
parce qu'il fait un travail
de position ou la gestion du temps elle
est tactique ne sont pas présentes et là
il est en train de tagifier NiAl le bout
en bout
et en grande difficulté le roi noir est
très loin et il y a l'espace au passé
roi C3 roi C4 roi B5 terminé
voilà et cavalier des deux et voilà KB2
pardon et voilà le sondage en une minute
pour Fatou le sondage qui apparaît tout
en haut du chat les gars si vous voulez
voter sur la vue que vous préférez et du
coup guéri
qui prend la tête du coup dans ce
premier set démonstration en plus en
allemand je suis dégoûté mais il a
démonté quoi
de cadrage à moins qu'il ait qu'il
épousé
on a rien vu
les gars on peut voter encore là préfère
ce type de position je trouve que la
finale de tout à l'heure ou c'était
vraiment moyen là
on peut jouer aux échecs mais il prend
l'espace notre ami
d'être ami guéri il est retourné de la
pose bien motivé je sais pas ce qu'elles
ont été les mots du coach sauf mais très
souvent si tu veux parler il perdait
quand il s'est beaucoup en fait et là du
coup en Bullet il réfléchit plus et du
coup c'est ce qu'il fait
[Musique]
chacun ou pas du coup on va devoir
remettre on va devoir remettre notre
tête Kevin donc sort un peu tes
États-Unis
incroyable LG 4 et jouer merci à tous ça
nous fait ça nous fait plaisir les
votants
de jouer où on met la dame H2 peut-être
discrètement pour le cavalier C7 un
moment pour les pions triplés là comme
c'est moche
regardez cette position de Bullet
incroyable à Nice joue à toute vitesse
Adam G3 peut-être mieux
il y avait plusieurs fois des pots
triplés dans ce maintien
attention qu'un petit deux r en Bullet
ça peut commencer à faire
ça peut clairement faire tester ça je
trouve Aniche dans de très bonnes
dispositions 15 secondes contre 40
et il a pas eu là il a un bon bon
sursaut d'orgueil regardez comme c'est
joli à 4 à 3 normales mais bon
on se laisse prendre en G4 ça fera des
pions
attention que camaïeu carte va être un
coup avec tout reprendre
la finale mais bon c'est très dur mais
bon ça tient encore c'est pas ça il est
quand même coriace il se laisse pas
battre comme ça
non mais là il va souffrir un sale je
sais tout regarde qui a été raté je
crois par guérir avant American qui
avait les yeux qui défendent des G4
il arrive toujours à trouver des coups
de défense de vitesse quoi avec très
très peu de temps et trouve toujours des
coups c'est
heureusement j'ai ce qu'on a bien passé
ou c'est maths
on a bien passé allez
2h dans le
c'est maintenant
je perds
de jouer ça là pierre tag là franchement
là c'est la première franchement c'est
une sale tronche l'histoire
c'est facile à jouer
en plus
alors vous voyez pourquoi je dis ça ben
simplement ça donne un jeu de pièces
blanc de folie après cela te fait coller
deux fois
on est un peu coincé quoi en effet comme
un bon saucisson
et là
voilà
je vais galérer là
c'est pas simple
il faut convertir tu as bien raison
souffre
qui peut tomber un peu n'importe quand
donc des sacs pour faire fermer ce fou
ces quatre
pour les pions il sait qu'ils vont pour
le coup c'est du beau jeu mais
c'est qu'il est mal du coup il tente des
choses et en pratique c'est vraiment
intéressant il y a tous les pions qui
tombent ça fait trois pions maintenant
tu as quatre bientôt
c'est le gros bazar cette position
4 éventuellement un joueur fond la
caisse ce sont ils ont pas le temps de
réfléchir les gars
[Musique]
parce que la position est très
déséquilibrée
le manque de temps dans cette position
en très compliqué à jouer vous voyez il
y a bien c'est poussé Usain Bolt
jusqu'au bout
là c'est chaud parce que si le Cavé s'en
va il peut y avoir des jeux maintenant
attention attention là effectivement
comment on va réussir à sécuriser droit
c'est pas facile parce que ça E5 d'un F3
pour passer ici
en 50 derrière taper sur R7
pour les deux mais j'ai l'impression que
les les noirs
qu'est-ce qu'il fallait jouer
précisément avec plus de secondes à la
pendule bravo NiAl c'est bien
pour je fous ces quatre tours
et oui c'est le gars
t'assure encore mg8 mais d'un point F8
mais pourquoi tu manges pas
ouh là là qu'est-ce qui se passe il
s'est passé les trucs très très puissant
c'est pas vrai
égalisation là c'est la concentration
maximum pour guérites Guiri qui va
gagner le Bullet incroyable
et vous le savez peut-être pas mais moi
je suis obligé de partir à 20h50 en plus
tu as eu des réponses pour le non
t'inquiète pas c'est pas un souci je
vais continuer seul elle a vu live de
stouf non mais là je suis et en plus je
parle pas en vainqueur comme on dit hein
pour te dire est-ce que j'ai gagné ou
pas enfin je t'écris quelque chose j'ai
gagné
si tu as un petit message de stouf et
ben tu peux pleurer si tu vois rien et
ben c'est que c'est horrible c'est
horrible il reste 19 minutes de Bullet
et malheureusement Kevin doit nous
quitter parce que parce que il a un
tournoi de badminton
et c'est ça
on a on a deux matchs on aura les deux
matchs merci merci Fatou et
du coup je vais je vais vous laisser
pour pas voilà pour pas mettre mon
équipe mal je vous dis à très bientôt si
tu fais ce que j'ai quelque chose à
faire techniquement est-ce que tu veux
que je m'enlève tout et puis moi je mets
la vue où je suis tout seul heureusement
que tu me l'as dit avant stream sinon je
l'aurais pas fait
je vous fais des bisous je vous dis à
très bientôt on se revoit demain pour
moi merci surtout en tout cas merci
tu me fais mal parce que je vois la
vente je sais pas ce qui me fait mon
petit mon petit bonhomme NiAl l'âme il
est en train de se faire retourner
t'inquiète je te pose encore on écrit
ok salut à tous et je me sens mal pour
ce soir
allez à très bientôt
bonne soirée à toi
à bientôt ciao ciao salut Ciao
alors du coup nous on va passer dans
l'autre scène du coup les gars la scène
où
celle-là je suis désolé façon au milieu
de partie du coup je suis tout seul
Kevin nous a quitté les gars pour cette
deuxième moitié de de Bullet donc nous
on est clairement pour guérir les gars
par rapport à nos Paris avec avec Kevin
je peux pas supporter
enfin je peux pas je vais pas supporter
Niall Sarine dans ce match
donc énorme qui sont bien rentrés là qui
peut tomber les pièces noires regardez
la colonne HC pour la tournoi les gens
sont vraiment pas mal ici
gagnant dans ma chambre
le Bullet qui commence qui tourne très
très mal pour pour Sarine qui va être
mené pour la première fois dans ce match
incroyable incroyable
qui est des 4 à 4 tours
anus il se laisse pas impressionner et
toujours devant autant prise
pour avant le pion qui avance
oui excuse-moi merci merci beaucoup j'ai
je l'avais oublié ce petit plus un qu'il
faut que je que je change je te remercie
et c'est changer
merci beaucoup de sablier
le sablier qui va aussi le qui va aussi
le temps
E4 et le pion qui va être perdu en fait
attention quand même au matin je me
rends 5 un jour de pas se faire enfermer
mais là normalement technique il y a
plus qu'à pousser les pions cavalier E8
qui va vouloir être joué un jour
attention en maths qui a été raté
peut-être
ça aurait été ça aurait été colère je
pense chez Kiri
on met le roi
allez on monte le roi on commence à
pousser cinq
par contre je sens que je suis pas sûr
pour l'instant
plein de ressources il est très très mal
mais il se bat énormément c'est ouf hein
ça va marquer qu'avec ces 6 attention
donc il faut venir défendre quelqu'un
vient en C7 et puis après les pions qui
poussent je pense que c'est terminé
cette partie
s'y perds pas autant normalement et
c'est abandon les gars dans cette
position
abandon de Niall
et du coup on repart oups pourquoi les
gars est-ce que cette vue elle n'est pas
faite bon je vais remettre les caméras
je suis désolé les gars
[Musique]
erreur technique tout à l'heure
je vous mets les caméras très très vite
ça me prend à peu près
à peu près 30 secondes et demi
30 secondes et demi pas plus
pas plus hop
et c'est bon repart sur l'autre scène
que j'ai réussi
à remettre rapide désolé pour ces petits
problèmes donc Guy elle est blanc cette
partie
et il mène au score 11-10 pour pour
guéri dans ce match c'est incroyable
c'est incroyable et franchement Kevin
qui disait tout à l'heure que à chaque
fois je le rase sur le finish et bah
franchement bah c'est vrai là
franchement c'est ouf lyrics a été mené
pendant tout le match et là d'un coup
qui revient un petit peu comme par magie
c'est juste assez incroyable
allez c'est pas fini encore c'est pas
fini
pas fini du tout encore dans mash4 il y
a quand même Annie Greg encore une fois
un bel avantage avec la case 4 puis on
F7 là prise prise Sarine qui collapse
complètement dans cette fin de match
qui collapse complètement cavaler
prendre des cadres
ok E6
et ça a l'air la complètement
complètement fini je vois pas de coup en
fait
ça marche pas il y a toujours le
contrôle ici cavalent de partout ça a
pas l'air très très bon ça prise j'ai
pas un cavalier quelque part genre
cavalier donc
ça a l'air d'être rideau
il ne joue pas il est gourmand guéri il
prend tous les pions
tout retrouver
mais les joueurs je vous rappelle les
joueurs ils sont ils sont fatigués là
ils ont fait un gros gros match c'est
difficile de jouer en pullet après tout
ça là il y a peut-être un perpète qui va
arriver
le roi G1 ça m'a l'air trop tendu et
échec roi là ça fait nul la F3 je ne
peux pas jouer parce que si je vois rien
F3 nul ok nul sympa
ça rime qui était quand même perdant
encore une fois
qui était perdant mais il a réussi qu'un
à se refaire allez on repart sur la
table
sur
1000 points il est vraiment important
pour pour Kevin je pars encore une fois
pour Kevin parce que du coup on avait
parié et en cas de Fanny dans un 7
c'était c'était beaucoup beaucoup
c'était la pluie la pluie de sable les
gars
donc là ça va il a sauvé les meubles
donc dans la 5 cavaliers des deux
et Guillaume qui s'est bien préparé il a
fait un bon travail de préparation parce
qu'on voit qu'avec les Noirs il a quand
même jamais vraiment eu de problème il y
a toujours réussi à avoir des bonnes
positions
et du coup c'est assez cool tu vois là
ok que si rocks avec avalé prendre des
deux donc trois obligatoires et
maintenant 8 qui peut bloquer un peu le
pion E3 et taper un jour ce truc fou H6
sur le pion de 3 car j'aime bien ces
positions cavalier B8 d'accord donc il
veut revenir par ici avec le cavalier
moi j'aurais bien fait tout remis des
fois il faut acheter mais bien je suis
assez content de mon plan
maintenant
c'est pas encore qui a pas encore
abdiqué
que un point d'écart dans ce match c'est
hyper chaud c'est 5 va sûrement être
joué je pense qu'il faut gérer 50 en
tout cas parce que tu le joues pas il y
aura un problème peut-être plus tard sur
le pion c'est
prise et on joue du coup sur le sur le
pion 3
B6 un jour je suis pas sûr de B6 à cause
de la classe C6 mais c'est vrai quand
même que le fou doit être stable en C5
là il est pas vraiment stable avec ce
cahier cette déforme et on est patient
donc
ça me fait un peu peur à chaque fois
je préfère aussi ok j'ai 5 plus tard
donc
en tout cas
[Musique]
gris fait une belle partie avec les
noirs
il a pu isoler il y a le pion ici en
trois qui arrivent belle petite case
pour les Noirs aussi salut comptoir
c'est à toi
qui va arriver avec le pion qui va
avancer ça peut faire peur ça aussi
est-ce qu'il y a moyen que je puisse
arriver à ramener mon full attaque genre
un G5 fougères 6 je suis pas sûr parce
qu'il y aura toujours le 4
mais si jamais j'arrive à décoller sur
roi d'ici et pousser le pion ça peut
être pas mal du tout pour les noirs
pas sûr du tout donc là il est encaissé
ici l'attaque le plus F3 c'est fou que
le reposer mais les pions blancs qui
sont tous sur casse blanche attention ça
peut être ça peut être chaud pour pour
Sarine donc là les pions qui sont
échangés elles gardent les tours Guiri
il veut vraiment un jeu pour le gain à
fond donc un pion de plus mais attention
où j'ai même pas eu pardon qui partaient
là qui avait le four en prise j'avais
pas vu
quel âge 3 c'est important
il a pas mangé le pion pourquoi il a pas
mangé H3 que se passe-t-il
du roi qui peut monter il a raté ouais
j'avais pas vu moi j'ai un petit délai
en fait avec ma caméra
et du coup le roi qui va monter le pion
qui a avance la tour qui est passive ça
risque de perdre ici pour pour Aniche
incroyable
très attends reprends je crois échec
c'était quand même pas mal
tu es quand même pas mal et après on
poussage 5 c'est le contre jeu c'était
le gros contre jeu du coup de de des
Noirs mais là du coup il y a pas contre
je parce que j'ai aucune poussée là et
ce pion là il est beaucoup trop loin
ok chaque ça va être perdu reste encore
8 minutes dans dans ce match et après
cette partie très probablement et ben on
aura une égalité
avec 11,5
[Musique]
là technique le pion qui avance voilà
c'est terminé je pense qu'il peut
abandonner allez
11 ennemis et ça fait deux parties déjà
que ça arrive ne perd plus du coup c'est
peut-être la remontada encore une fois
dans ce match
alors fuj4 donc la foule
5 cette thématique de sa position D5
cavalier des 4
ça c'est assez connu après puis on prend
la cavalier prend fou ou deux j'imagine
pour jouer F4 peut-être un jour puis on
prend ça aussi intéressant pendant un
camion de 4 mais le fou de cette ferait
un peu la gueule derrière le pion à 5
kevin est parti
il verra demain demain
pour les deux matchs qu'on a on a so
contre apps et on a après
[Musique]
Nakamura contre parano
donc là j'aime beaucoup les blancs
encore une fois H6 échanger les dames et
changer les fous pardon les pions d'Amal
sont en 6 c'est bon ça marche
fautes si ça la maintenance
salaire mat fois
ça marchera ici c'est un thème qui
existe souvent fautif ça existe un
certain
pouvait peut-être
faire quelque chose est-ce 4 ok Google
pour pour farine avec les noirs
[Musique]
éliminer la défenseur du roi et de
ramener les pieds ce qui a un coup qui a
l'air sympa aussi et il va ramener les
tours sur H et ce qui est ouf c'est que
ça règne il a 0 contre le jeu ça va être
dur pour ça rien de créer quelque chose
ici faut de F4
mais c'est une partie qui on a
l'impression quand même que les Blancs
jouent tout seul après F4 Fousse C4
c'est extrêmement facile à répondre
tellement c'est compliqué à fou c'est le
garde qu'elle va être jouée dame
tranquille la fou bet3 il va jouer 5 un
jour il va ouvrir la position
il fait peur par contre il me fait très
très peur il a plus de temps la pendu il
se prend un quatre fois tu vas te donner
la tour ramener la tour là haut
H2 pro allemand qui couvre dame géant et
menace des matelas haut c'est hyper
complexe hyper complexe
de partout c'est plus suite pour les
blancs sur ordinateur
[Musique]
très prochainement tour de un Dame des
trois et je pensais à l'abandon mais en
fait pas du tout il pousse et c'est
abondance cette partie tu as c'est
incroyable les gars gros spectacle en
tout cas en bullette de ces deux joueurs
dirait qu'il nous régale on dirait qu'il
était pas favori dans cette cadence
ambulette mais qui nous régale
complètement dans ce match
allez on repart sur cette jobava
tu as ouverture ou guéri il fait une
super
super couverture à chaque fois il a
jamais eu de problème pour l'instant
il rejoue son petit F5 comme tout à
l'heure à chaque fois avec un petit
Caval aussi c'est F4 qui est pas mal
hein
en vrai c'est beau duel c'est beau duel
il reste 3 minutes dans ce match et anus
qui mène de un point
ce qui est absolument incroyable 5 et
demi 1 et demi en Bullet c'est quand
même quand même vraiment intéressant et
quel est le 5 c'est parti là ils l'ont
déjà eu cette partie tout à l'heure en
blitz ils ont fait exactement la même
prise
par exemple
dernière
probablement et fou prend H3 qui arrive
là prise cavalier prend le dame qui
arrive en H4 ça peut faire très très mal
et du coup Sarine qui joue aux dames B3
la foule aussi probablement l'ordi Manon
c'est dans l'oreillette il faut prendre
les gars faut prendre les deux et dame
D7 avec Dame G4 la marche 3
ça c'est l'oreillette de stouffe il y a
aussi fou prend une tranche de qui gagne
mais a priori il faut manger deux dames
des 7 très très bien aussi mais pas
pareil allez
par contre
c'est un peu dommage voyant un Bullet on
peut pas trop réfléchir en fait il faut
vraiment jouer des coups vite et plus à
l'instant et si tu passes plus de 30
secondes sur un coup ben il y a qu'après
toujours pas à la rencontre calculé
c'est un peu chaud tu vois par exemple
là s'il y a que des faux projets qui
fabrique c'était compliqué etc je pense
qu'il aurait dû y aller plutôt que de
repartir en arrière parce que la caméra
il a quand même investi beaucoup
beaucoup de temps dans son calcul et
maintenant il est il est en retard la 10
secondes de moins
et 10 secondes de moins en Bullet c'est
énorme donc il se passe quoi il y a
plein d'échanges
Dame des 7
et
plein de cases pour les blancs il y a la
case 5 et les tours qui vont rentrer
franchement j'aime bien les blancs en
pratique parce que
tout est ouvert quoi des blancs toutes
les colonnes le plus on va récupérer des
cartes peut tomber
ça reste très très chaud bien sûr ça
rien qui est qui est ma de nouveau mal
au temps
qu'est-ce qui se passe là tout est en
prise prise était possible aussi
justement j'ai mangé des quatre
et après je dois F7 et tour là tour là
est-ce que c'est clair ça
pas mal ah ouais ça va l'air bien il y
avait une sorte de maths Tour Eiffel
voilà et tourmate
ça va être perdu
[Musique]
ça va être perdu celle-là je pense il
faut garder les deux pions passés c'est
important F3 roalin pourrait ça marche
pas je peux pas le faire j'ai trois
malheureusement peut-être du coup faire
G3 enfin G4 pardon puis G3
bien joué je crois qu'il empêche G4 et
le roi blanc pas passer
il fait échec alors j'ai 8 jouer bientôt
c'est gagnant pour les blancs mais
où il y a non j'ai cru qu'il y a eu
maths comme ça mais il y avait roi F3
excusez-moi
la fausse la fausse annonce est quand
même un jour
j'ai quatre jouets malheureusement on
n'a jamais j'ai trop que de roi je crois
ça va être perdu sûrement
j'ai trois attention
OK
time is up les gars time is up c'est la
dernière partie si Guiri ne perd pas
cette partie le match est terminé
en revanche si giriper
et bien on va être un départage assez
hyper compliqué je vois que l'ordinateur
change d'avis à chaque fois
c'est impossible
c'est ultra compliqué
à chaque coup ça change c'est beaucoup
trop compliqué
beaucoup trop complexe
et là les blancs qui gagnent ici parce
que le roi coupé le roi noir voyez qui
est coupé et c'est égalisation dans le
money time pour pour guéri donc OK
il va y avoir quatre parties
supplémentaires
[Musique]
de Bullet en une plus une et aussi à
l'issue des détails
[Musique]
ok ok
les joueurs sont encore égalité après
après
les bullets il y aura une pause avant
l'Armageddon
on va avoir en tout cas guéri a quand
même plutôt impressionnant de Bullet
donc
[Musique]
on va voir un peu ce qui va se passer
on sent qu'il est tard quelle heure il
est d'ailleurs
en Inde c'est ce qu'on va faire est-ce
que tu peux nous le dire je crois qu'il
est 3 ou 4h30 de plus 3h30 un truc comme
ça il est 1h40 du matin ah ouais ok
minuit 40
voir on sent un peu la fatigue arrivé
quand même
[Musique]
ouais ça fait ça fait beaucoup ça fait
beaucoup quand même
et donc ils vont lancer les parties ça
part de suite
les gars j'aurais jamais pensé qu'il y
aurait un magasin
qui aurait un départage
Guerry qui était trois points avant le
Bullet et qui a réussi à
qui a réussi à rattraper son retard de
la partie il a même gagné le match avant
cette partie
mais je joue à ce niveau à d'accord non
mais c'est des machines tu t'imagines
même pas en fait ça arrive il Blitz
enfin c'est un professionnel il passe sa
vie à faire du Bullet sur sortir comme
t'inquiète hein allez ils vont changer
l'ordre donc on va remettre du coup
cette scène désolé pour le changement et
du coup garer à blanc donc Gary pardon
guéri à blanc donc c'est quatre parties
de une plus une ou trois si jamais la
3-0 ou 2,5
sur 3 ou 3 sur 3 et ben on jouera pas la
quatrième bien évidemment ça ne sert à
rien
donc dirait qu'il repart dans cette
position avec H4 qu'ils étaient très
très bien passé d'ailleurs dans la
première dans la première partie et il
rejoue du coup dépend le 5 donc là du
coup il joue contre le fou G7 c'est
important donc positionnellement en fait
sont bien il y a un casse des 5 et
5 ans qui est mauvais derrière le pion
dans 5 donc je pense que c'est vraiment
ce qu'il veut faire après il y a bien
sûr des idées avec F4 il faut acheter
pour attaquer avec H5 il y a plein
d'idées ici sympa
alors F4 a été joué
de 4 pour venir un jour F6 pour éliminer
le fou le fou noir en laissant beaucoup
E5 avec cavadio 4 cavaliers F6 ça risque
de raser complet cette idée là qui est
aussi il faut prendre un F7 du E6 il y a
plein de choses je pense que que guéri a
trouvé le point faible de de Sarine dans
cette Bullet ça fait deux fois qu'ils
ont sorti de position et deux fois que
farine se fait complètement outplay si
on reprend un cavalier 5 ça va être
matin
qui décide aussi d'ailleurs encore plus
fort la tour on la mange pas je pense
dommage 7 attaque ici
tout aussi seul coup
tout va jouer F5 et attention que si on
mate pas et ben ça peut se retourner
contre nous
F5 c'est hyper chaud sur
[Musique]
l'ordi donne égal après ça
ils disent que c'est nul
= 0,0 peut pas savoir pourquoi les gars
c'est juste impossible mais en pratique
c'est mille fois mieux pour pour les
blancs c'est un mode 3D comme forcer
et là madame il va être perdu
normalement alors à se cacher la Tour
Eiffel 5 encore mais tourgé 5 peut-être
peut mettre fin à la partie d'apprendre
à 7 il y avait un clouage et là je pense
que anis Aniche perd cette première
partie pardon excuse-moi farine perd
cette première partie de Bullet donc ça
fait 1 0 dans les départages
allez ça arrive qui part sur des
systèmes avec avec
trois foulées d'eux la changer un petit
peu de son de son schéma Joe Bavière
pour jouer quelque chose de différent
donc il vous laisse un bien un plan très
standard avec le cavalier qui aviron H7
G5 normalement c'est assez connu c'est
le plan de l'attaque est indienne qu'on
peut aussi d'ailleurs jouer avec les
Blancs aussi
donc X3 est-ce que des cinq c'est un
coup
mais ça va un peu peur quand même de
donner ça alors c'est 5 ah j'avais pas
vu qu'il y avait une découverte sur la
dame ce qui est pas mal du coup ça
ouvrir ça ouvre du coup la colonne E et
le pion étroit qui est un genre pourra
partir il y a aussi l'option des quatre
qui est plus protégé par un pion étroit
ça c'est vraiment pas mal cavalier aussi
ce qui avait F4 cavaliers des 4
franchement c'est c'est hyper
intéressant j'aime beaucoup la pollution
de sa de guérir
bien cette partie là il a déjà un pied
en quart de finale
car elle prend des cartes il collabs
complet Sarine il collapse complet il
donne un pion en un
et ça va être ça va être dur là c'est
pion de plus avec en plus je pense
l'attaque avec un casque blanche qui
peuvent être assez forte donc Giri qui
propose l'échange de pièces
tac tac vous aussi peut-être qui va
arriver même des cinq c'est un coup qui
peut qui peut arriver un jour et si
jamais je mange des six que va-t-il se
passer
mystère
des sacs me plaît bien
des cinq alors c'est cool leur dire je
l'ai vu après mais je pensais que
c'était pas forcément cool après ça il y
a qu'un fou à 4 coups B5 peut-être
essayer d'éliminer un peu des pièces qui
défendent le temps des 5
donc là il a rendu le pion mais toujours
la paire de fou chez les Noirs le pion
passé blanc en fait il avance pas trop
voyez parce qu'il est quand même pas mal
bloqué par les pièces noires qui sont
quand même plutôt bien bien placés
des fois 4 là je sais pas si on met le
four en F8 C5 ou si on passe plutôt en
E5
bel avantage noir ici encore une fois
les pièces blanches sont mal coordonnées
on a pris B3 attention au pion qui
avance
trop D8 sûrement un faux 5 qui va
arriver pour essayer de la s’emparer de
ce pion
cavalier T4 attention aux fourchettes
cavalier sa tension je pense que je peux
manger des ciseaux
et le pion qui va avancer
tout recettes qui était raté apparemment
tourage 4
c'est hyper dur il y a un problème sans
clouage quand même ici
est-ce que on peut en profiter de cette
louage c'est pas sûr moi j'ai mis très
bien joué
on peut plus faire tour ici
allez laquelle manger des pions mais au
final ça reste quand même assez drôle
les chances de nul pour pour guérir
parce qu'il y a trop de pièces les pions
sont en face
tout peut se passer
et encore des pièces et encore plein de
choses à faire il y a 1-0 pour guéri
pour ce départage
et cette partie si peu ne pas la perdre
ça c'est quand même plutôt bien pour lui
une très belle opération
pour deux
[Musique]
je vais vite
ce qui arrive ah oui
ah oui compliqué
et il a perdu autant
incroyable il s'est presque laisse
tomber allez un partout dommage un gris
qui avait qui avait fait déjà plus dur
cette partie
allez un partout dans cet département
du coup il va nous rester encore trois
parties c'est sûr
c'est sûr que
excusez-moi je dis n'importe
quoi seulement s'il y a un départage
d'armag est temps d'arrière donc C5 pour
récupérer la carte de 5 plus tard pour
le cavale
mais j'aime bien cette position pour les
blancs généralement ils font problème
sur le plan des 6 tout ça
c'est une sorte ça fait des 5 une sorte
de Benoni comme structure mais là j'ai
pas besoin de faire en fait des 5 la
rupture E5 très souvent
ok des 5 hyper normal ici voir si je
peux manger ici mais je pense pas
j'aurais toujours le fond en l'air en F4
c'est un peu le thème avant ses
positions
c'est un peu le thème
donc C4 on va bouger le fou cette fois
faut se défoule bien je sais pas trop il
va le mettre Lambert OK
car il est encaissé un
respecte pas le sacrifice de de guéri a
fait le même sacrifice un petit peu
avant dans le match
il avait des prix aussi de prendre
d'ailleurs et là c'était un bel avantage
noir ici dans cette position
[Musique]
ça arrive qui prend l'avantage avec son
plus là
et le mauvais fou d'ailleurs c'est c'est
très difficile ici pour
pour Aniche
qui a une position qui est qui est très
mauvaise
après ça reste du Bullet ça reste
compliqué tout ça il a enlevé il a
enlevé le cavalier attention il y a
cavaleo 3 qui interception
qui va perdre la caloche
extrêmement dur en plus elle va les
prendre ici à Tours qui arrive avec le
fou bien qui va tomber ça va être
abandon je pense de guérir dans cette
partie
ça va être abandon parce qu'il y a le
foot qui tombe
ça continue
ça me sac peut-être il y a pas grand
chose
donc Aniche qui va être dos au mur dans
ce match obligation de gagner
la prochaine partie pour arriver à
l'Armageddon
et si il ne gagne pas la prochaine
partie ça va être ça va être
dommage qui est pas de maths
il y a rien du tout allez
peut-être les gars la dernière partie du
match peut-être
il faut absolument que guéri gagne avec
les Noirs absolument obligé
si bien que les noirs
et ben vous assistez au premier
au premier
Armageddon de cette édition de speech
elle est B6
prise
ok je pense que Sarine il joue il joue
solide là il a eu celle là pour avoir
une structure un petit peu symétrique
pour pas prendre trop de risques alors
avec les Blancs je vous rappelle que que
Sarine lui avec
avec une nulle et ben il remportera ce
match et que guéri à l'obligation de
gagner avec les noirs
à surveiller faire attention
c'est pas simple du tout pour pour
gagner ça avec les noirs de position
c'est pas facile parce que la position
sont quand même plutôt
[Musique]
qui ripe s'en fout synonyme de perte de
match ouh là là incroyable ta Kevin
Kevin qui est encore chatté en vrai
incroyable
franchement ce match c'est ouf
c'est assez triste quand
le match se termine comme ça sur une
faute de souris c'est très très triste
mais bon c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
la souris fait partie du match fait
partie du jeu c'est c'est malheureux
c'est
et c'est comme ça
allez trois quatre il y a deux pions de
moins mais là pour gagner ça avec les
Noirs c'est juste complètement
impossible en fait
c'est impossible contre un Sarine qui se
qualife les gars c'est juste impossible
ça peut gagner mais contraintes ça rime
comme ça non
il y a quand peut-être le pion B3 qu'on
peut aller bouffer
e mal au temps sur un malentendu
il peut toujours se passer des choses
mais bon entre nous
on n'y croit pas trop mais c'est
vraiment dramatique cette fin de match
en vrai c'est
pas de chance quoi
c'est pas de chance
quand même aller on peut se battre
encore un peu là c'est qu'un pion de moi
attention la fourchette là qui arrive
ouh là là attention
attention la fourchette et franchement
Guillaume il y a pas encore qui a pas
encore perdu ce match
qui me permet de tenir la tour qui va
revenir ici très bien ah c'est pas fini
en fait j'ai trois oui il y avait
je crois que ça gagne la tour
enflammé c'est possible mais il me
semblait alors moi je suis super
et surtout en plus vu ce match avec la
faute de cerise quand même pas juste et
du coup je suis vraiment pour guérir
dans ce match
allez il y a ce pur en prise avec
cavaliers qui va venir en Détroit
peut-être il y a plus de temps là c'est
hyper compliqué cavalier prend B4 pro F6
c'est hyper chaud hyper hyper chaud ce
match j'y crois pas j'y crois pas
je pensais que guéri allait abandonner
direct après son esclick et les gars il
est encore dans le match il a pas encore
perdu d'ailleurs il est même loin
d'avoir perdu c'est pas clair du tout
cette finale
allez
bon c'est quand il y a quand même pas
mal de chance de nuls dans cette finale
c'était d'ailleurs même nul c'est nul
mais franchement les gars est-ce que
c'est pas une de faire nulle cette
partie avec les noirs
après les mises cliques
je sais pas enflammé hein il a raté que
j'ai trop
c'est un gros match en vrai
là
facile même moi j'attendrai même moi je
fais nul comme
pas sûr encore moi je suis quand même
une bonne quiche je peux la perdre je
suis capable
mais bon non en vrai en vrai c'est
triste comment le match se termine parce
que
tu mérites pas de faire une photo comme
ça
personne mérite de famille
c'est pas de chance quoi
il a failli tomber
difficile c'est toujours chargé 3 mais
ça marche pas il tricote tricote en tout
cas il va tout tenter il va tout
orienter dans cette finale pour
[Musique]
pour ne pas faire mieux mais là les
échec tu peux rien faire
tu peux rien faire j'ai trois c'est la
seule chance avec le clouage mais ça
marchera pas
la failli tomber encore une fois
mais normalement ça c'est terminé
ça fait un peu précis on range 3 échecs
c'est nul trop facile la prise prise
[Musique]
c'est dur du coup Guiri qui est éliminé
de ce
robot
hyper hyper chaud vous voyez
sa pièce ici après B5 franchement
[Musique]
et à pousser dans la finale en vrai ça
méritait une win il y a eu l'air un
karaté que j'ai pas j'ai pas regardé
et cavaliers contours parce qu'il y a un
petit clouage de la rater ça
guéri c'est vraiment dommage qu'il rate
ça parce qu'il est 20 secondes à la
pendu contre deux vous voyez et même moi
je l'ai vu donc
à cette triste pour ça mais en tout cas
gros GG en tout cas à ça rime qui a
quand même gagner ce match c'était pas
rien quand même guiris et numéro 7
mondial c'est c'est un grand monstre
donc voilà donc demain le gars à partir
de 15 heures on va avoir le gros duel
entre so Wesley sauf un habitué des des
speechesso qui est juste monstrueux
contre a des autorov qui est lui-même
champion du monde de parties rapides
donc il est jeune il a 18 ans il a 2700
hello maintenant et il est champion du
monde en titre de rapides donc ça va
demain un très très gros match en tout
cas
et suivi à 19h de l'entrée sur le ring
de
icaru Nakamura contre par avion
donc deux gros matchs en tout cas à
suivre demain donc de 15h à 23 ans ça va
être assez Sexy en tout cas les gars
merci à tous d'avoir suivi le stream
tellement hyper cool
et puis j'espère vous revoir du coup
demain
tous sur sur la chaîne pour la suite des
événements de ce match donc merci à tous
bonne soirée et puis et puis à très très
bientôt ciao ciao